und jetzt hören wir alexander gauland
ihn vorsitzender der fdp-fraktion die
krise ist die stunde der exekutive und
zugleich die große versuchung der
exekutive den staat als vormund bürger
zu etablieren
frau bundeskanzlerin dass es offen sich
nicht nur in ungarn so mit ihrer
begriffs schöpfung öffnungs diskussions
orgien hat die bundeskanzlerin eine
basta mentalität offenbart als
opposition betrachten wir es als unsere
pflicht über öffnungen und alternativen
zu diskutieren
die vergangenen wochen haben eins
deutlich gezeigt die weit überwiegende
mehrheit in unserem land geht mit der
ansteckungsgefahr sehr vernünftig und
diszipliniert um die menschen halten
abstand voneinander sie versammeln sich
nicht warten geduldig vor geschäften
viele tragen mundschutz die
quarantänemaßnahmen laufen längst selbst
organisiert der staat ist dabei
weitgehend überflüssig
es wird also zeit die beschränkung der
grundrechte zu lockern und die
schutzmaßnahmen in die private
verantwortung der bürger zu überführen
das kann natürlich nur mit augenmaß und
intelligenz funktionieren die
schrittweise lockerung der
quarantänevorschriften ist nicht nur
wirtschaftlich geboten sondern auch
gesundheitlich wir sind eine
gesellschaft in dem übergewicht und
krankheiten der kreislauf systems die
häufigste todesursache sind wie wird
diese bilanz aussehen wenn millionen
menschen sich monatelang eingesperrt
fühlen wie geht s krebskranken deren
behandlungen gestreckt werden
wie geht es menschen die mit
depressionen allein zu hause sitzen wie
viele psychische erkrankungen kommen bei
denjenigen dazu deren existenz durch die
quarantäne bedroht oder gar vernichtet
ist wie viele tote es sind dadurch
zusätzlich zu erwarten
das sind fragen frau bundeskanzlerin die
kann man nicht einfach mit diskussions
verboten wegwischen
ich dachte
ich darf daran erinnern dass länder wie
südkorea taiwan und singapur ohne lok
durch die krise gekommen sind nicht das
einsperren der gesamten bevölkerung ist
die lösung sondern der schutz der
risikogruppen und meine damen und herren
wenn am selben tag bayern verkündet das
oktoberfest ausfallen zu lassen und
berlin ankündigt das
demonstrationsverbot für den ersten mai
zu lockern entsteht zurecht der eindruck
in der bevölkerung dass die exekutiven
einfach nicht wissen was sie tun
wie wäre es beispielsweise wenn die
regierung festlegte dass rentner und
angehörige von risikogruppen separate
einkaufszeiten erhalten zb in vormittag
da die meisten geschäfte inzwischen
einlass personal an ihre türen gestellt
haben lässt sich das leicht realisieren
warum dürfen gaststätten und biergärten
nicht unter auflagen öffnen
eine mehrwertsteuersenkung sehr gerne
finanzminister
bei einer bei einem 0 umsatz ist
überhaupt keine lösung in dieser frage
auflagen könnten seien halbierung der
anzahl der tische und damit distanz
herzustellen massen pflicht für das
personal
wenn die regierung es schafft genügend
schutzmasken bereitzustellen könnte in
den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln masken
pflicht bestehen
die menschen sind vernünftig genug ihr
persönliches risiko einzuschätzen und
sich gegenseitig zu kontern
meine damen und herren völlig unzumutbar
ist aus unserer sicht einen
zweitwohnsitz nicht aufsuchen zu dürfen
die schriftstellerin monika maron um ein
beispiel zu nennen erhielt ein formblatt
zugeschickt in dem die gemeinde in der
die berliner autorin selbst fielen
jahren ein zweitwohnsitz unterhält
anordnet sie habe nicht nur ihr haus
sondern gleich das bundesland
mecklenburg vorpommern zu verlassen
folge sie der anweisung nicht werde
umgehend strafanzeige erstattet
bitteschön wo sind wir in diesem lande
angekommen wenn so was möglich ist als
eine der freiheit der bürger
verpflichtete partei lehnen wir die
ersten ansätze zur bargeld abschaffung
ebenso ab wie die sogenannten euro-bonds
das ist der punkt wo wir sogar auf
seiten der bundeskanzlerin stehen
meine damen und herren von otto von
bismarck stand die beobachtung dass er
das wort europa immer im munde
derjenigen politiker gefunden habe die
von anderen mächten etwas verlangten was
sie im eigenen namen nicht zu fordern
wagten wie war es diese beobachtung
das virus hat auch der eu lektion
erteilt es hat der union im wortsinne
ihre grenzen aufgezeigt in der krise
ziehen sich die menschen in die soliden
und vertrauten strukturen zurück das ist
im kleinen die familie im großen der
nationalstaat
wir müssen als abgeordnete die frage
diskutieren ab wann die maßnahmen gegen
die pandemie einen größeren schaden
anrichten als die pandemie selbst und
wir werden
diese diskussion nicht auf dem frau
bundeskanzlerin
denn wir müssen die verantwortung für
das was jetzt kommt wieder in die hände
der bürger legen
es ist nicht aufgabe der regierung es
ist aufgabe der bürger hier zusammen zu
stehen
ich bedanke mich alexander gauland
vorsieht der afg fraktion mit kritik wie
er sagte an bevormundungen durch die
regierung gegenüber der bevölkerung aber
gleichzeitig mit dem vorschlag der 1000
seiten führen einzelne
bevölkerungsgruppen einzuführen rolf
mützenich der vorsitzender der spd
fraktion ist der nächste redner
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine fraktion
unterstützt die vorsichtigen und
verantwortbaren schritte die die
bundesregierung zusammen mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten in der vergangenen
woche mit auf den weg gebracht haben
es waren richtige schritte die eine
stärkung der eigenverantwortung aber
eben auch auf der anderen seite des
zusammenhalts dieser gesellschaft
abbilden und letztlich auch notwendig
gemacht haben
sie reflektieren etwas was dringend
immer noch der beachtung bedarf nämlich
dass wir schaffen ein intaktes
gesundheitswesen aufrechtzuerhalten an
beginn einer pandemie und nicht in der
mitte oder am ende dieser pandemie und
wo es mir und meiner fraktion auch
insbesondere darauf ankommt und ich
vermisse oft auch vielleicht diese
hinweise es geht eben auch um den
gesundheitsschutz der arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmern gehen den geschäften
in den betrieben und das wird man nicht
von heute auf morgen schaffen können und
deswegen sage ich sehr deutlich ja diese
schritte sind verantwortbar und sie sind
eben auch angemessen auf der anderen
seite finde ich müssen wir seit den
wochen und wir haben hier des öfteren im
deutschen bundestag jetzt darüber
gesprochen es als beachtlich empfinden
wie stark die bürger solidarität ausüben
aber eben auf der anderen seite auch dem
selbstschutz nachkommen und vielleicht
erinnern wir uns dann auch später an die
kleinen geschichten der
nachbarschaftshilfe demjenigen in meinem
wahlkreis der mit einem leierkasten
durch die straßen geht und einfach musik
spielt an die menschen die in ihren
wohnungen zurzeit sich aufhalten und
sich nicht bewegen können alles das sind
glaube ich dinge die mut machen und sie
haben recht und auf der anderen seite
frau bundeskanzlerin sind es die
demokratischen zumutung mit denen man
sich auseinandersetzen muss und deswegen
ist es
richtig dass viele in diesem land viele
organisationen viele letztlich eben auch
vereinen aber auch der ethikrat
juristinnen und juristen medienvertreter
die berechtigten fragen nach der
einschränkung der rechtsgüter stellen
und ob sie verhältnismäßig sind und das
erreicht auch dieses parlament und
deswegen sage ich ja dieses parlament
ist notwendig um diese schritte zu gehen
um darüber zu sprechen aber eben auch
entscheidungen zu treffen weil nämlich
die kontrolle und das selbstbewusstsein
voraussetzung dafür ist dass dieser
demokratische staat auch in seiner
gestalt erhalten bleibt und deswegen
sage ich sehr selbstbewusst die
parlamentarierinnen und parlamentarier
sind die ansprechpartner vor ort wer
wenn nicht wir werden darauf
angesprochen wo vielleicht etwas noch
nicht richtig funktioniert und nicht
ändern zum beispiel ein hamburger
unternehmen das erblindete menschen eine
berufsperspektive gibt die sehende an
die hand nehmen und durch ihre welt der
erblindeten führen
sie bekommen keine hilfe von der kfw
weil der eben nur gewerbliche
unternehmen zurzeit dazu ermächtigt
haben diese helfen auch zu gehen und
deswegen sage ich die parlamentarier und
parlament notwendig um korrekturen auch
für diesen riesigen weg zu machen und
zum zweiten
wir erleben vor ort dass junge menschen
uns darauf ansprechen dass sie jetzt
ihren praktikumsplatz verloren haben den
sie genommen haben um im herbst diesen
jahres sind die ausbildung zu gehen und
sie vermuten dass sie jetzt keinen
ausbildungsplatz bekommen deswegen sagen
ist sehr klar wir müssen alles dafür tun
dass die gemeinschaftliche aktion für
die jungen menschen die wir gebildet
haben für gute ausbildung auch gelingt
und zur not auch mehr außerbetriebliche
ausbildungsplätze in zukunft zur
verfügung zu stellen dafür brauchen wir
das parlament und ich bin sehr dankbar
dass wir sehr selbstbewusst diese fragen
stellt
und es ist auch eine voraussetzung dafür
dass demokratie gelingt weil ich glaube
die menschen erleben was diese soziale
und demokratische rechtsstaat leiste in
seiner großen gemeinschaft in diesem
raum aber auch darüber hinaus weil eben
ein parteien regierungen ein personen
regierungen es nicht schaffen alle
warten sozusagen auf die entscheidung
der machtzentrale
wir haben es erlebt autoritäre
herrschaft ist nur am eigennutz und
letztlich am zurückdrängen der
opposition interessiert und deswegen bin
ich stolz dass dieses deutschland dass
diese gesellschaft keine
antidemokratischen reflexe zeigt sondern
im gegenteil hinter diesen sozialen
rechtsstaat steht und sozialdemokraten
sozialdemokraten wollen daran weiterhin
mit werk meine damen und herren
und in diesem zusammenhang muss ich auch
sagen bin ich irritiert das doch immer
wieder und das haben krisen
offensichtlich so ansicht die krise
nutzen geplante vorhaben oder eigenen
interessen nachzueifern und deswegen
sage ich es ist empörend und überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehbar dass unternehmen
die um öffentliche hilfe nachfragen auf
der anderen seite dividenden oder boni
ausschütten wolle aussagen wollen
das ist nicht akzeptabel meine
und nicht erinnere zum beispiel an ein
unternehmen wie die lufthansa die in
schatten dieser krise ein klein 2
nämlich die germanwings liquidiert hat
und ich finde das ist ein weg den wir
genauso öffentlich anprangern müssen wie
manches fehlverhalten oder
antidemokratische reflexe die teilweise
hier eben auch aus diesem hause leider
kommen und zum dritten
das werde ich auch meinen
koalitionspartner nicht ersparen können
dass wir in dieser woche nicht über die
grundrente sprechen können ist für uns
nicht hinnehmbar
wir werden das weiterhin einfordern weil
sie können nicht auf der einen seite
balkon reden halten für die
systemrelevanten berufe die eben nur
kleine einkommen haben für die wir die
grundrente eben auch gebildet haben
auf den weg zu gehen und dann auf der
anderen seite eine gesetzliche beratung
den vorzuenthalten deswegen sage ich wir
wollen dass diese grundrente hier in der
nächsten sitzungswoche im parlament
gelesen dass meine damen und herren
und wenn es darum geht dass wir wissen
dass wir diese pandemie dass sie uns
noch einige zeit im griff haben wird
dann lohnt es sich trotzdem über die
zukunft nachzudenken und frau
bundeskanzlerin sie haben über die
konjunkturprogramme und vieles andere
auch gesprochen deswegen sage ich ja wir
müssen zurzeit auf die aktuelle krise
reagieren aber bereits darüber
nachdenken was werden wir dann in den
nächsten wochen und monaten tun um
sozusagen den motor wieder anlaufen zu
lassen und dann erlebe ich manche alte
altmodische diskussionen der
steuersenkung
da frage ich mich manchmal in welcher
welt leben diejenigen die diese frage
ansprechen weil nämlich die menschen
sich zur zeit überhaupt nicht die frage
stellen können sie vielleicht mit einer
kleineren einkommenssteuer besser über
die runden die fragen habe ich noch
arbeiten
überhaupt einkommensteuer zahlen zu
können und deswegen sage ich wir müssen
uns auf den weg machen vor den
bedingungen der zukunft eben auch eine
förderung innovativer techniken und
geschäftsmodelle mit auf den weg zu
bringen und das zweite auch darauf
möchte ich meinen koalitionspartner und
die bundesregierung ansprechen
wir reden über die verletzbarkeit
bestehende wertschöpfungsketten
wir wollen dass das risikomanagement
offengelegt hat ja und in der tat wir
erleben dass offensichtlich diese
lieferketten auf existenzielle krisen
keine antworten geben deswegen bitte ich
sie lassen wir uns uns zusammensetzen
überlegen dass dieses was wir schon im
koalitionsvertrag niedergelegt hat
nämlich das lieferketten gesetz auf den
weg zu bringen und bietet dieses
lieferketten gesetz möglicherweise auch
die chance dieses risiko management und
die frage eben von besseren lieferketten
möglicherweise auch gesetzlich
nachzufragen
ich glaube meine damen und herren darauf
kommt es an frau bundeskanzlerin meine
fraktion unterstützt sie in den auslagen
dass es deutschland nur so gut geht wenn
es eben europa gut geht deswegen sind
die ersten schritte die gemacht worden
sind genau die richtigen schritte die
eben auch wirken können aber das heißt
nicht dass wir aufhören dürfen das heißt
dass wir weitere antworten geben müssen
und ja es wird ein schwieriger ein
herausfordernder prozess sein dass wenn
die gemeinschaftsbildung und die
fiskalunion gelingt wir natürlich auch
über neue instrumente werden nachdenken
müssen und sie auf den weg zu bringen
und ich glaube insbesondere in einer
krise wo es nicht darum geht ob man
falsch gewirtschaftet hat sondern wo man
eben durch diese pandemie unverschuldet
herausgeforderte ist ist der richtige
zeitpunkt diese notwendigen fragen zu
stellen meine damen und herren und zum
anderen
ich will sagen die pandemie hat auch
gezeigt dass es reale feinde gibt für
die ganze menschen deswegen lohnt es
sich vielleicht auch mal innezuhalten
und darüber nachzudenken ob es wirklich
noch angemessen ist diesen wahnwitzigen
rüstungswettlauf diese unglaublich
großen milliarden an euro und an dollar
militärausgaben überhaupt noch zu
akzeptieren und festigen sagen wenn sich
der demokratische und soziale
rechtsstaat in dieser krise als die
richtige regierungsform beweisen wird
warum können dann nicht demokratien
gleichzeitig den notwendigen impuls für
das friedliche miteinander stiften
ich bin überzeugt dass eine soziale und
gesunde zukunft dann gelingt wenn wir
gleichzeitig feindschaften abbauen um
gutes zu tun müssen wir beides schaffen
die aktuelle krise bewältigen und
unseren grundsätzen treu bleiben vielen
dank
der vorsitzende der spd fraktion rolf
mützenich mit seiner antwort auf die
regierungserklärung der bundeskanzlerin
und er hat trotz vieler einigung im
koalitionsausschuss heute nach durchaus
auch auf eine ganze reihe von
diskrepanzen zwischen union und spd
hingewiesen gleichzeitig aber auch
betont die kontroll- und debatten
funktionen des parlaments gerade in
einer phase in der es einschränkungen
ebenso gibt wie große hilfspaket nötig
sind und damit auch belegt dass
behauptungen es dürfe gerade keine
diskussion zu bestimmten maßnahmen geben
schlicht falsch ist und christian
lindner
die kogit 19 pandemie war die coop 19
pandemie ist eine unbekannte heraus die
unser land nahezu unvorbereitet
getroffen hat deshalb haben wir hier in
diesem parlament in großer einmütigkeit
einschneidende maßnahmen gemeinsam
beschlossen
wir haben unser land heruntergefahren
wir haben grundrechte grundfreiheiten
eingeschränkt wie zu keinem zeitpunkt
zuvor in der geschichte unseres
das habe freie debatten mitgetragen
teilweise haben wir sogar dazu ermuntert
kontrolliert das gesellschaftliche und
wirtschaftliche leben herunterzufahren
und sind einige wochen ins land gegangen
nun wissen wir mehr und ist das land
weiter der gesundheitsschutz ist
unzweifelhaft eine aufgabe für die
staatliche verantwortungsgemeinschaft es
gibt eben dinge die gehen über die
möglichkeit der individuellen
verantwortungsübernahme hinaus helgoland
aber aber die zweifel an der
verhältnismäßigkeit des zustandes
insgesamt und die zweifel an der
geeignetheit einzelner maßnahmen sind
ebenfalls gewachsen
und weil die zweifel gewachsen sind frau
bundeskanzlerin endet heute auch die
große einmütigkeit in der frage des
krisenmanagements
sie haben sie haben vielfach frau merkel
von vorsicht gesprochen und auch heute
hier den eindruck erweckt wer ihren
gedanken von vorsicht nicht teilt müsse
sich fahrlässigkeit oder
leichtfertigkeit vorwerfen lassen so
auch am montag in ihrer öffentlichen
stellungnahme das sind aber nur
scheinbar alternativen vorsicht und
leichtsinn freiheit und gesundheit
dürfen wir nicht und müssen wir auch
nicht gegeneinander ausspielen das land
ist weiter hier ist von allen rednern
heute und nicht nur heute unterstrichen
worden wie verantwortungsbewusst und
solidarisch die menschen sind
gottseidank versorgungsengpass
versorgungsengpässe werden bekämpft die
öffentliche gesundheitsämter und auch
das gesundheitswesen insgesamt haben
ihre kapazitäten erhöht also
das land ist weiter und deshalb frau
bundeskanzlerin muss jetzt darüber
gesprochen werden wie wir gesundheit und
freiheit besser vereinbaren als in den
vergangenen wochen es ist jetzt möglich
vom dazu die wissenschaftlichen
grundlagen für die regierungspolitik
haben sicher regelmäßig verändert erst
ging es um die verdopplung zahlen dann
um die reproduktions quote erst sollten
60 bis 70 prozent kontrolliert infiziert
werden und dann heute geht es um die
absolute eindämmung masken waren erst
unnötig masken waren erst unnötig dann
war ich rede nur über die politik der
regierung nicht über meine haltung ich
bin noch dabei zu reformieren
kolleginnen und kollegen masken masken
waren erst unnötig dann waren sie viren
schleudern dann waren sie eine
höflichkeit geste dann waren sie ein
dringendes gebot und heute gibt es eine
maske pflicht ich werfe das niemandem
vor verehrte anwesende aber lachen sie
nur anhören müssen sie sich trotzdem ich
werfe das niemandem vor
ich werfe das niemandem vor aber eins
ist doch ersichtlich viele
entscheidungen sind nicht gesicherte
erkenntnis sind nicht zur wahrheit
geronnene forschung sondern sind
politische entscheidung und als solche
können und müssen sie hier diskutiert
werden
ich bedaure in diesem zusammenhang das
wort von den diskussions orgien
dahinter steht ein anderes bild von den
menschen als wir es haben die menschen
werden durch politische debatten nicht
verunsichert sondern eher bestärkt dass
mit ihren interessen und einschätzungen
sorgfältig umgegangen dass sorgfältig
abgewogen wird der staat ist immer
begründungspflicht ich wenn er
grundfreiheiten einschränke
und deshalb muss darüber diskutiert
werden tatsächlich beklagen tatsächlich
beklagen beobachter wie der
politikwissenschaftler wolfgang merkel
zufällige namensähnlichkeit oder der
philosoph julian nida-rümelin das wäre
in unserem land über öffnung diskutieren
will mindestens unter einem moralischen
rechtfertigungsdruck gerät
gott sei dank haben wir eine unabhängige
justiz das bundesverfassungsgericht
hatte geurteilt dass in der kurve 19
pandemie das versammlungsrecht nicht
einfach pauschal eingeschränkt werden
kann und das landgericht hamburg hat die
unsinnige 800 quadratmeter regelt
verworfen das zeigt die unabhängige
justiz lässt sich durch regieanweisungen
der politik nicht einschüchtern
ein gutes zeichen und tatsächlich und
tatsächlich die 800 quadratmeter regel
oder auch die diskriminierung der
gesamten gastronomie hält auch
virologischen ansprüchen nicht stand da
sind wir bei den alternativen professor
gerd krause vom helmholtz institut für
infektionsforschung für insekten
infektiologie in braunschweig ein
frühere regierungsberater in zeiten der
ehec krise hat zu ihren beschlüssen vom
vorvergangenen donnerstag gesagt die
seiten der sache nicht nötig die
orientierung an einzelnen sparten und
quadratmeter zahlen seien unsicher
ansehen sich man könne sogar die
gastronomie wieder öffnen
entscheidend sei nur der abstand
zwischen den tischen oder genauer gesagt
entscheidend ist nicht was geöffnet und
was geschlossen ist
entscheidend ist ob überall die
hygieneregeln eingehalten werden und zum
zweiten die orientierung an der rer
produktionsquote professor alexander
kekule sagt dazu gestern im zdf das sei
inzwischen das goldene kalb
krisenmanager
weil auch die reproduktion
deutschlandweit insgesamt steigt wenn es
ein dramatisches infektionsgeschehen an
nur einem einzigen hotspot gibt da sagt
der faktor für das ganze land gar nichts
über die reale situation aus und deshalb
macht es keinen sinn für deutschland
insgesamt einen shutdown zu verhängen
sondern wir müssen viel stärker regional
gegen infektionsketten vorgehen weil
dann haben wir eine chance feier
gesundheit wirksam zu vereinbaren wird
sammer als jetzt und zum dritten
unverändert auch nach wochen wird diese
pandemie bekämpft mit instrumenten die
im grunde seit dem mittelalter bekannt
sind
quarantäne das kommt die bekannt ist von
den 40 tagen die schiffe warten mussten
bevor sie anlegen durften masken
isolation
das sind die mittel des mittelalters
auch im jahr 2010 sich wo uns eigentlich
smart ihre instrumente durch die
digitalisierung zur verfügung stehen
und hier haben wir die dringende frage
an die regierung wo sind die apps wo ist
mindestens die zwei xing app die wir
brauchen und infektionsketten
nachzuverfolgen
die digitalen defizite deutschlands
kosten uns gesundheit wohlstand und
freiheit und das ist nicht länger
hinnehmbar
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen eine
alternative krisenstrategie ist möglich
weil unser land weiter ist und eine
alternative krisenstrategie ist auch
nötig wegen der gesundheitlichen folgen
auf die allenthalben hingewiesen werden
heute auch in den medien
wenn chefärzte beklagen dass sich in den
abteilungen wo es um herzerkrankungen
geht schlaganfälle sich niemand mehr
meldet weil die menschen angst haben
das sind gesundheitliche folgewirkungen
die sozialen belastungsfaktoren wenn
menschen sich nicht mehr austausch nicht
mehr in der freiheit bewegen können ja
und auch wer angst um die
wirtschaftliche existenz hat nimmt
schaden an der seele
sie haben erklärte nicht durchaus recht
steuerentlastungen allein helfen da
nicht
sie haben gestern nacht für die
gastronomie eine steuerentlastung
beschlossen und ich gebe ihnen recht die
hilft nichts weil eine reduzierte
mehrwertsteuer wenn kein umsatz anfällt
hilft kein betrieb überleben
also sollten sie dafür sorgen dass es
schnell unter verantwortbaren
gesundheits gelegen und wieder zu einer
öffnung kommt grundsätzlich liegen sie
aber falsch in einem land in dem es vor
einer corona pandemie bereits die
höchste steuerquote in seiner geschichte
gab muss umso mehr danach wieder die
möglichkeit geschaffen werden dass die
menschen eigenkapital aufbauen und
private vorsorge wieder stärken können
und ich sage ihnen eins er müsse nicht
und er sah wie auch den kollegen von
grünen und linkspartei
wir diskutieren gerne nach der krise mit
ihnen auch wieder über die
vermögensabgabe und die vermögenssteuer
jetzt müssen uns nur darum kümmern dass
es überhaupt noch eine wirtschaftliche
substanz gibt die sie danach besteuern
wollen
und meine damen und herren wir werden
intensiv uns auseinandersetzen müssen ob
tatsächlich weitere planwirtschaftliche
eingriffe notwendig sind damit nicht wie
sie das eben auch angedeutet haben mit
ihrem lieferketten gesetz darüber können
wir gerne streiten wir glauben dass es
erforderlich ist die infektionskette zu
unterbrechen aber irgendwann werden wir
auch die interventionszeiten in unsere
freiheitliche wirtschaftsordnung
unterbinden müssen denn der start der
ist mit sicherheit nicht der bessere
unternehmer
an dieser einsicht hat sie auch nach
corona nichts verändert
christian lindner der vorsitzende der
fdp-fraktion auch parteivorsitzender mit
einer rede die mich etwas ratlos
zurücklässt den offenbar hätte christian
hinten ja schon vor wochen gewusst wie
man dieser corona krise dieser pandemie
bei kommen muss und das ist angesichts
von diskussionen auch unter erfahrenen
und bekannten virologen die aufgrund der
sich verändernden situation auch immer
wieder zu leicht anderen anderen
einschätzungen können
ralph brinkhaus für die unionsfraktion
in diesem land durch sehr viel geduld
durch sehr viel arbeit und denkt nicht
nur an die menschen die im
gesundheitswesen arbeiten sondern auch
an die vielen eltern die ihre kinder zu
hause betreuen und zu hause beschulen
wir haben in der tat große
einschränkungen erlebt möchte nur an
eine sache erinnern das osterfest für
viele christen nicht in kirchen
stattfinden können
das war in weiten teilen des landes
selbst 1945 nicht der fall
das heißt also wir haben eine menge
menge menge dinge auch auf uns genommen
und wir müssen jetzt aufpassen neuen
damen und herren das war das was wir
aufgebaut haben nicht wieder einreißen
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir
darüber diskutieren wie gehen wir mit
lockerungen um wie vorsichtig sind wir
wie es die balance zwischen den
interessen von arbeit von zusammenleben
und auf der anderen seite von gesundheit
ich möchte dazu nur eins sagen wir
können viele viele sachen auch im
wirtschaftlichen bereich wieder
korrigieren nicht alle das ist mir sehr
wichtig aber was wir nicht korrigieren
können ist der verlust eines
menschenlebens und daran muss man bei
dieser sache auf überdenken
und deswegen sollten wir diese
diskussion die wir mit dem
ministerpräsidenten haben die wir
insgesamt haben auch mit großem bedacht
mit großer ernsthaftigkeit führen
aber wir sollten sich führen dies
vorausgeschickt möchte ich auf vier
punkte eingehen fangen wir an mit dem
parlament mir hat das überhaupt nicht
gefallen was herr gauland gesagt hat und
nur sehr begrenzt gefallen was herr
lindner gesagt hat und herr lindner ich
glaube mal dass justiz eingeschüchtert
wird das überlegen sie sich noch mal
gucken sie sich ihr redemanuskript mal
an aber ehrlich gesagt wir sind hier im
parlament und dazu gehört hier
auseinandersetzung dazu gehören erregtes
zwischenrufe wenn irgendwas passiert
weil das parlament meine damen und
herren ist der auch die politische
entscheidungsfindung stattfindet und
deswegen ist es gut und richtig dass wir
heute diese debatte haben deswegen ist
es gut und richtig dass es heute diese
regierungserklärung gibt und auch wenn
ich da teilweise selbst daran beteiligt
bin koalitionsausschuss und auch
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen sind
keine verfassungsorgane wir sind hier
das verfassungsorgan meine damen und
herren
und vor dem hintergrund ist es auch hier
der ort wo wir die debatte führen müssen
wie wir auch mit ethischen fragen
umgehen wie wir mit ethischen fragen um
den was zu lockern ist wie wir mit den
ethischen fragen umgehen was wir denn
als diese gesellschaft ertragen können
und deswegen herr bundestagspräsident
ist es unser aller aufgabe dieses
parlament auch am laufen zu halten auch
in der krise auch in der pandemie und
wir werden in den nächsten wochen zeigen
dass wir vollumfänglich beraten dass wir
die regierung kontrollieren dass wir
ergänzungen und verbesserungsvorschläge
machen wie rolf mützenich das gesagt hat
und dass wir uns auch die freiheit
nehmen zu kritisieren es ist wichtig und
richtig gewesen dass die exekutive
schnell gehandelt
das ist eine republik ist aktive und das
nehmen wir als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion und ich glaube auch
alle anderen fraktionen sehr sehr ernst
meine damen und herren
ein zweiter punkt der mir sehr wichtig
ist freiheit
das ist gerade mehrfach angesprochen
worden und das nehme ich auch sehr 1 die
freiheit überall dorthin zu gehen wo man
hingehen möchte die freiheit sich zu
versammeln und die freiheit natürlich
auch ohne staatliche interventionen zu
nehmen
meine damen und herren wenn ich mir die
freiheit nehme zu einer versammlung
zugehen wenn ich mir die freiheit nehme
in einem fußball stadion zu gehen dann
schränke ich die freiheit von anderen
ein betreffe nicht nur eine entscheidung
für mich in der pandemie sondern ich
treffe auch eine entscheidung für die
schwächeren
die sich nicht wehren können die diese
freiheit nicht haben das ist der copd
kranke wer zu hause liegt das ist der
ältere mensch ja nicht besucht werden
kann
und das sind viele viele andere und
deswegen ist mir das viel zu
eindimensional immer das große lied der
individuellen freiheit zu sägen herr
lindner sondern wir müssen uns auch mal
mit den menschen beschäftigen die diese
freiheit in dieser pandemie nicht haben
und wir müssen sehr aufpassen dass wir
durch unsere eigenen freiheitsrechte
nicht andere menschen in dieser freiheit
einstreichen das gehört nämlich auch zur
weiter
dritter punkt wirtschaft ja wissen was
nicht nur befremdet ist dass wir nahezu
im stundentakt neue vorschläge kriegen
die alle auch ihre individuelle
begründung haben die alle irgendwo auch
getriggert sind durch briefe durch mails
die wir kriegen wenn man jetzt noch
irgendwo helfen muss
und wenn man wie wir in den wahlkreisen
unterwegs ist und die individuelle note
aussieht noch das reisebüro
busunternehmer gastronomie oder auch
betriebe sind wenn man sieht dass
menschen in kurzarbeit sind und nicht
mehr genug zum leben haben dann nehmen
wir das auch sehr ernst aber wir müssen
eine sache vielleicht auch mal beachten
all das was wir beschließen übrigens
auch das was wir gestern abend
beschlossen haben kostet geld viel geld
was von irgendjemand mal wieder
zurückgezahlt werden muss und wir müssen
wirklich aufpassen in dieser zeit wir
müssen wirklich aufpassen in dieser zeit
bei all den guten was wir momentan
machen und übrigens auch machen müssen
und übrigens uns bis jetzt auch noch
leisten können dass wir nicht maß und
mitte bei dieser ganzen sache verlieren
und dass wir im wochentakt nachlegen
werden und das ist eine geschichte
das ist eine sache da gucke ich auch
durchaus einige mitglieder der
bundesregierung an die da meinen was
über die medien immer wieder treiben zu
müssen was wir machen muss da gucke ich
auch den ein oder anderen
ministerpräsidenten an
und deswegen kann ich nur eins sagen wir
als unionsfraktion verstehen uns auch
als hüter der fiskalischen solidität
auch in zeiten der krise liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und jetzt möchte ich zu dem vierten
punkt kommt das ist das thema europa da
bin ich und ich sag das mal sehr
diplomatisch auch wenn ich in die eine
oder andere ausländische zeitdruck sehr
irritiert wer meint dass nur derjenige
ein guter europäer ist und im übrigen
gibt es doch auch einige hier im
wissenschaft und politik dieses lied
aufsehen wer meint dass nur derjenige
ein guter europäer ist ja der
vergemeinschaftung von schulden das wort
redet der verschweigt eine menge der
verschweigt nämlich dass wir hier in
deutschland und das möchte ich an dieser
stelle ausdrücklich mal sagen weil wir
es auch gerne tue noch ausüben grund tun
nicht nur der größte nettozahler in der
europäischen union sind nicht nur der
größte garantie und kapitalgeber sind
bei all den rettungspaket nicht nur die
last der migration und der flucht der
legale und illegale migration mehr
übernehmen als jedes anderes
europäisches land und das ist so ist
dass wir hier in deutschland in der
krise das kostbarste überhaupt anderen
ländern zur verfügung gestellt haben was
meint nämlich intensivbetten da wird
auch nicht drüber geredet und das tun
wir auch gerne weil wir in der
europäischen solidarität sind und dass
wir deutsche in gestalt von angela
merkel und olaf scholz ein vier säulen
paket auf den weg gebracht haben wo wir
über den esm über die europäische
investitionsbank über den artikel 122
über europäische haushaltsmittel ein
hilfspaket auf den weg stellen für
andere europäische länder denen es nicht
so gut geht die mit der krise noch nicht
so gut fertig geworden sind was ich
wirklich sehen lassen kann
das sind mehrere hundert milliarden das
hätten wir uns alle irgendwo vor einigen
wochen nicht vorstellen können und dann
in dieser situation in zweifel zu
stellen dass wir nicht solidarisch
europäer sind
ich würde mir wünschen dass der ein oder
andere auch in anderen ländern in europa
der immer das hohelied mit großen worten
von europa sinkt so solidarisch ist wie
wir das hier in deutschland sind
beinamen
und deswegen sage ich ganz ganz
eindeutig wir stehen dazu wir stehen
dazu dass wir unseren europäischen
partnern helfen und wir stehen im
übrigen auch dazu hier hat müller sitze
nicht hier
dass wir auch denjenigen helfen die noch
schwächer sind und die noch probleme
die wird afrika wahrscheinlich stärker
betreffen als sie uns betreffen wird in
europa da stehen wir zu und das machen
wir auch aus aufrichtigen ernst weil wir
uns dieses europa nur so vorstellen
können dass wir solidarisch sind und
dass wir zusammenhalten in der krise
aber es muss auch erlaubt sein das eine
oder andere zu hinterfragen und meine
damen und herren wir handeln
andere haben da oftmals nur
lippenbekenntnisse wir werden und die
bundeskanzlerin hat darauf hingewiesen
wir werden nicht mit dieser pandemie
fertig werden wir werden unser normales
leben wahrscheinlich erst wieder
zurückbekommen wenn wir einen impfstoff
haben
und das muss man den menschen sehr offen
und ehrlich sagen wir sollten da auch
keine falschen hoffnungen erwecken
aber wir haben in den letzten wochen und
monaten gezeigt dass wir vernünftig mit
dieser krise umgehen können und ich habe
es vor vier wochen hier auch gesagt dass
wir zusammenhalten in diesem land und
dass wir eine große gemeinsamkeit
entwickelt wir haben eine wirtschaft die
ist sehr sehr stark und wir haben gute
maßnahmen auf den weg gebracht um diese
wirtschaft zu stützen
und deswegen habe ich die ganz ganz
große zuversicht immer noch dass wir
sehr sehr gut geschlossen gemeinsam aus
dieser krise herauskommen werden und ich
glaube man das ist auch die aufgabe bei
aller parlamentarischen diskussion die
wir haben und bei aller kritik die wir
haben das wir sind in diesem land zufall
sich aus dieser krise herauszukommen und
ich glaube diese zuversicht können wir
diesen land mit guten gewissen geben
weil wir wissen was zu tun ist und weil
wir auch so mit dieser krise umgehen
meine damen und herren dass wir
verantwortungsvoll sind vielleicht gehen
wir manchmal einen schritt zu weit
vielleicht gehen wir manchmal ein
schritt in die andere richtung aber wir
sind immer bereit das auch zu
korrigieren und zu verändern
diesen weg werden wir weitergehen und
wie gesagt bin überzeugt davon dass der
deutsche bundestag der richtige ort ist
der öffentlichkeit klar zu machen vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit student aus
der vorsitzende der cdu/csu-fraktion
hier im deutschen bundestag hat noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass es in einer so
schwierigen situation in der welt durch
die korona krise geraten sind auch
wichtig ist zu korrigieren auch zu
verändern also entscheidungen
nachzujustieren wenn man festgestellt
hat dass sich auch die sachlage
verändert hat und was kann man schon in
einer solchen pandemie weit voraussagen
dietmar bartsch ist der nächste redner
vorsitzende der linksfraktion
meine damen und herren ob
bundeskanzlerin sie haben von einer
ausserordentlichen von einer ernsten
situation gesprochen von der größten
bewährungsprobe vor der unser land steht
dass die krisenbewältigung in
deutschland weitgehend passabel läuft
dafür haben sie vielen gedankt das ist
natürlich den großen verständnis in
weiten teilen der bevölkerung auch zu
danken will mich dem auch im namen
meiner fraktion ausdrücklich
anschließend begriff solidarität und
wieder einen anderen klang ja meine
damen und herren es geht nicht
zuallererst um krisenbewältigung sondern
es geht zuerst um krisenbewältigung
undicht zuallererst um parteipolitik und
deshalb will ich auch ganz klar sagen
dass ich das als eine frechheit ansehe
wenn die union in dieser situation
versucht die grundrente zu versenken
sie haben schon die ursprungsidee von
heil über die monate immer mehr
verwässert und ich sage ihnen es ist
ganz einfach schäbig bei den kassieren
pflegekräften und logistischen zu
applaudieren und dann gegen die
grundrente zu sein was glauben sie denn
werde
und rente bekommen es sind genau die
menschen die jetzt dieses land am laufen
halten
es sind krokodilstränen die sie beim
viele von den altenpflegerinnen von den
paketboten sind diejenigen die später
auf eine grundrente angewiesen sein
werden und deshalb ist das unfassbar was
sie machen und nicht zu akzeptieren
meine damen und sie begründen das ganze
dann mit dem geld was ja in dieser
situation schon was besonderes ist aber
da muss ich dann sofort mal an die pläne
der verteidigungsministerin erinnern
die wollen jetzt 45 neue kampf gewonnen
war teilweise atomwaffen fähig
anschaffen
das ist unverantwortlich der
verteidigungshaushalt steigt und steigt
kurz vor der pandemie haben sie noch mal
um 6,4 milliarden erhöht und das sah
machen sie jetzt und dann wollen sie der
kassiererin die rente kürzen dass es
inakzeptabel uns bedroht keine fremde
armee uns bedroht ein virus und deswegen
brauchen wir auch ein corona
entsprechenden verteidigungsetat
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass die
initiativen für weltweite abrüstung
ergreifen wenn viel mehr geld eben ins
gesundheitswesen geflossen wäre und
nicht in aufrüstung dann hätten wir
heute eine ganz andere situation eben
eine viel bessere meine damen und dass
wir auch brauchen
natürlich brauchen wir einen anderen
umgang mit börsennotierten unternehmen
wenn konzerne weiter dividenden
ausschütten um eigentümer noch reicher
zu machen wenn boni an manager
ausgeschüttet werden und milliarden
eingesetzt werden um aktien
zurückzukaufen dann darf es keine
staatshilfe mehr geben
ich finde im übrigen ist es auch
unternehmerisch eine bankrotterklärung
in so einer krise geld abzuziehen aus
unternehmen wo man überhaupt nicht weiß
wo die reise hingeht dass es auch
unternehmerisch völliger unsinn deswegen
eine klare entscheidung der
bundesregierung wer heute boni zahlt der
bekommt auf jeden fall zukünftig keine
staatsunterstützung mehr
und wir zumindest die kleinigkeit eher
wenig bin freue mich dass alle
fraktionen des hauses die initiative der
linken mittragen dass wir die erhöhte
die erhöhung der diäten aussetzen ist
ein symbolischer aber wichtiger akt
herzlichen dank dafür
aber ich will in diesem zusammenhang
auch daran erinnern dass das kabinett
gibt die sehr wohl die sehr wohl auch
über 40 nachdenken vielleicht könnten
diese beiden wieder für sie auch ganz
interessant sein
am anfang meine damen und herren gab es
viel gemeinsames agieren jetzt wird es
zunehmend ein kommunikations server wo
merkel sie haben das völlig zu recht
kritisiert es droht ein chaos das am
ende auch die akzeptanz für die
maßnahmen massiv massiv reduzieren
könnte ihre krisenpolitik steuert jetzt
immer mehr auf einen flickenteppich zu
zu forsch haben sie gesagt ich teile das
es ist im übrigen deshalb
außerordentlich problematisch wenn die
korona krise zusammen fällt mit der kür
des cdu kanzlerkandidat und da sind herr
söder und herr laschet leider ein
stückweit verhaltensauffällig den müssen
sie ihre kritik als allererstes sagen
frau bundeskanzler es geht um das leben
und die existenz von menschen und nicht
um die taille
in der union meine damen und herren das
alles ist passiert mit härtesten
einschnitten in die grund und
freiheitsrechte
ja sie haben von einer demokratischen
zukunft gesprochen
das muss immer wieder laut ausgesprochen
werden weil es darf keine gewohnheit
werden dass wir diese einschränkungen
bei einem ganzen katalog von grund und
freiheitsrechten haben harte
einschränkungen müssen immer wieder
diskutiert werden und sie müssen noch
immer wieder begründet werden frau
bundeskanzlerin
das ist normalität und keine orte da hat
herr poß im übrigen sehr recht und diese
maßnahmen müssen enden so spät für
unbedingt notwendig aber so schnell wie
irgend möglich
es ist dringend angebracht immer wieder
darüber zu diskutieren weil es so
gewaltige einschränkungen sind und es
ist gut dass wir heute darüber intensiv
gesprochen haben ich will noch mal kurz
kapitulieren wie es dann überhaupt zu
der notwendigkeit dieser härtesten
einschnitte kam es gab viel zu wenig
vorbereitung warum wurden anfang januar
anfang januar keine masten gestellt
bestellten die lager aufgefüllt
warum gab es überhaupt keine
beschränkungen für reisen aus spüren
risikogebieten nach deutschland warum
gab es keine verbindlichen tests für
einreisende aus diesen gebieten
im januar hätten die alarmglocken
schrillen müssen meine damen und herren
es gab doch den pandemieplan des
robert-koch-instituts von 2012 da ist
das doch alles wunderbar aufgeschrieben
den haben sie voll und ganz ignoriert
aber eins zeigt diese krise ganz
deutlich die privatisierung und die
kommerzialisierung des gesundheitswesens
war ein fehler
sie ist mitverantwortlich für dieses
doch schon jetzt jetzt schaffen sie die
krankenhaus kapazitäten die sie
jahrelang wegrationalisiert haben und
sie sehen doch hoffen sich jetzt auch
dass die fallpauschalen der wahnsinn
sind man sieht es doch in dieser
situation ich möchte den erste
präsidenten herrn rainer zitieren der
sagt kliniken sind einrichtung der
daseinsfürsorge und keine
industriebetriebe krankenhäuser müssen
den patienten dienen nicht den profi das
muss ins kollektive gedächtnis
einbrennen ja meine damen und herren das
müssen wir ins kollektive gedächtnis ein
ich möchte ich möchte nochmal auf eine
besondere dimension bei kindern
hinweisen millionen kinder sollen noch
wochen monate lang zu hause bleiben das
kann und tragbare soziale und psychische
kollateralschäden bedeutet kinder frauen
und familien drohen die verlierer der
pandemie zu werden
es ist doch absurd wenn großen
kaufhäusern teilweise erlaubt wird
wieder zu öffnen und kindern de wird
verboten sich auf eine schaukel zu
setzen
da ist doch etwas schief das beispiel
der alleinerziehenden ist besonders
dramatisch 1,8 millionen berufstätige
alleinerziehende fast alles frauen
werden im stich gelassen wenn es für
diese frauen nicht bald betreuungs
lösung für die kinder geben eltern sind
eben keine erzieherinnen und erzieher
und auch keine lehrer und auch keine
therapeuten
es muss dringend kompensation geben sie
können nicht für junge familien alles zu
sperren und sie im regen stehen lassen
deswegen ist ein corona elterngeld in
linke und grüne das fordern einen sinn
eine sinnvolle idee
bitte denken sie darüber
und ich will auch noch mal daran
erinnern will auch noch mal daran
erinnern die kita empfehlung die messe
basiert ja im übrigen auf der leopoldina
studie
und da will ich folgendes festhalten in
der arbeitsgruppe zu dieser studie die
mehr meinung als wissenschaft ist waren
mehr männer mit dem namen jürgen als
frauen insgesamt
das erklärt vielleicht die ignoranz
gegenüber kindern und ihrer betreuung
meine damen und herren wir wir brauchen
dringend wir brauchen dringend einen
fahrplan frau gitta hat gestern darüber
gesprochen weil die familien weil die
alleinerziehenden licht am ende des
tunnels sehen müssen eigentlich hätte es
ihn lange geben müssen
ich erlebe wir alle erleben in dieser
zeit eine unglaubliche solidarität und
auch ein großes
verantwortungsbewusstsein in unserem
land viele menschen ziehen damit das
kann man gar nicht anders sagen aber ich
sage auch sonnen sie sich nicht in ihren
hohen zustimmungswerten die menschen
erwarten weiter antworten wann gibt es
in jedem altenheim ausreichend masten
waren gibt es flächendeckend es auch auf
antikörper hier muss wirklich mehr
passiert ja frau bundeskanzlerin sie
haben recht diese krise darf die
gesellschaft nicht zerreißen es besteht
aktuell die gefahr dass wir viel
schlechter rausgehen als wir reingehen
aber ich sage ganz deutlich auch es ist
doch eine chance es ist eine chance für
einen neuen verein anderen zusammenhalt
in unserer gesellschaft wie als linke
werden uns aktiv dafür engagieren
herzlichen dank gibt aber hat stärke
vorsitzende der links fraktion begrüßt
die neue solidarität im land ria sagt
spricht aber auch unter anderem von
verhaltensauffälligen
ministerpräsidenten und hat damit
offenbar auch bei der bundeskanzlerin
für ein klein wenig erheiterung gesorgt
der nächste auf der liste der redner
hier in dieser aussprache zur
regierungserklärung der bundeskanzlerin
ist anton hofreiter pro vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin
hier sind epidemiologisch weiter in
einer sehr sehr fragilen lage und in der
lombardei im elsass in new york konnte
man sehen welche schrecklichen
auswirkungen diese pandemie haben kann
im vergleich dazu sind wir in
deutschland bisher sehr glimpflich davon
gekommen dafür muss man sich bedanken
bei all den menschen die sich an die
regeln gehalten haben bei all den
menschen die eine wahnsinnig wertvolle
arbeit leisten in den
gesundheitssystemen allerdings auch bei
allen kassiererinnen und kassierer und
all denjenigen die unser leben am laufen
lassen
vielen dank und trotz der tatsache dass
wir bisher so glimpflich davon gekommen
ist war es und bleibt es einfach richtig
mit vorsicht und besonnenheit vorzugehen
und ja die debatte ist nötig und der
debatte ist möglich es bestreitet auch
niemand dass die debatte geführt wird
aber man muss sich bei der debatte sei
dann argumente anschauen
und warum gibt es eine begrenzung zb bei
den geschäften weil man aus
infektionsschutz gründen nicht will dass
die innenstädte wieder komplett voll
sind mit menschen weil dann nämlich
automatisch die abstände nicht mehr
eingehalten werden können
das ist die begründung dass man nur ein
teil der geschäfte auf macht und diese
begründung sollte ihnen von der fdp auch
zugänglich sein
[Applaus]
und wissen sie und wissen sie man sollte
einfach aufhören die eigene freiheit
schlichtweg zu verwechseln im recht des
stärkeren nämlich dass es eine vulgäre
form von freiheit
und deshalb und deshalb ist es einfach
ganz entscheidend dass wir intensiv
debattieren aber bei entscheidungen
vorsichtig vorgehen nicht so schnell und
nicht unüberlegt handeln
nächstens gefährden wir alles was wir
bis jetzt erreicht haben sonst gefährden
wir dass das gesundheitssystem nicht
überfordert wird
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
wirtschaftlichen kosten sind hoch
die fließbänder stehen still die
geschäfte sind geschlossen
kultureinrichtungen sind zu sozialer
einrichtungen sind zu künstlerinnen und
künstler können nicht mehr auftreten
wirtschaftliche existenzen sind
gefährdet arbeitsplätze sind bedroht
aber bei all diesen dürfen ja auch
keinen moment vergessen dass nicht nur
die wirtschaftlichen kosten hoch sind
sondern auch die sozialen kosten
bedrückend sind kinder drohen den
anschluss zu verlieren weil sie nicht
mehr in die schule gehen können familien
sind am limit menschen drohen dynamo zu
landen
über all das müssen wir debattieren und
deshalb muss bei vorsichtigen schritten
verantwortungsvollen schritten in
richtung öffnen sowohl die soziale frage
als auch die wirtschaftliche frage auf
augenhöhe behandelt werden
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nach
allem was wir wissenschaftlich wissen
werden wir mit diesem virus leben müssen
bis wir einen funktionierenden impfstoff
haben und deshalb ist in dieser zeit
eine der wichtigsten fragen
wie gelingt es uns die voraussetzungen
zu schaffen um die ausbreitung des virus
zielgerichteter einzudämmen
und dabei geht es sie haben das gesagt
frau bundeskanzlerin um testen testen
noch mal testen
es geht um die nachverfolgung der
infektionsketten durch die
gesundheitsämter
es geht darum eine app zu haben die
dabei hilft es geht um ausreichend
schutzausrüstungen und es geht darum um
masken nichts davon muss man allerdings
ehrlicherweise sagen ist neu das wissen
wir seit vielen wochen und ich habe
leider den eindruck dass in ihrer
bundesregierung nicht in allen
ministerium diese aufgabe mit dem
einsatz der entschiedenheit und der
tatkraft verfolgt wird wie es angebracht
wäre
noch vor zwei wochen hat uns das
wirtschaftsministerium geantwortet dass
die koordinierung der pandemie
wirtschaft in dem ministerium keine
priorität hat es ist schön dass jahr
altmaier scheinbar hat seine meinung
geändert hat
aber wertvolle zeit ist verstrichen und
auch bei der app hört man nichts gutes
und deshalb erwarte ich von ihnen dass
sie diese aufgabe als nationale als
europäische kraftanstrengung betrachten
und dementsprechend handeln
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
in der letzten sitzungswoche in großer
gemeinsamkeit ein ganz umfassenden
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
rettungsschirm aufgespannt
vieles davon hat sich bewährt manches
korrigieren wir manches fehlt noch die
erhöhung des kurzarbeitergeldes finde
ich ausdrücklich richtig aber dass sie
weiterhin ausgerechnet den ärmsten der
armen wenigstens temporär eine erhöhung
des arbeitslosengelds weiß verweigern
das finde ich ehrlich gesagt
unverantwortlich
und dass sie sich weigern ein corona
elterngeld einzuführen wenn man sich
anschaut unter welchem druck
insbesondere alleinerziehende aber alle
familien stehen finde ich desweiteren
unverantwortlich wissen sie wenn wir als
grüne und in meinen augen völlig zu
recht dafür streiten dass lufthansa
gerettet wird erwarte ich ehrlich gesagt
dass die union auch dafür streitet das
wenigstens temporär die ärmsten der
armen in unserer gesellschaft angemessen
unterstützt werden
wir erleben gerade einen wirklich
historischen einbruch unserer wirtschaft
es trifft menschen unternehmen staaten
weltweit für konjunkturelle maßnahmen es
ist angesichts der epidemiologischen
lage noch zu früh aber was jetzt klar
sein muss ist das wenn es möglich wird
es ein großes konjunkturpaket geben wird
ein großes investitionspaket geben wird
denn die unternehmen und die
beschäftigten brauchen
planungssicherheit die brauchen klarheit
wenn wir schon in zeitpunkt nicht
festlegen können muss man wenigstens
deutlich machen es wird ein großes und
umfangreiches paket geben und was auch
klar sein muss ist dass dieses paket
sich am klimaschutz am green deal
orientieren muss die letzten jahre waren
die heißesten jahre seit der
wetteraufzeichnung dieses frühe ist
bereits jetzt wieder deutlich zu trocken
wir drohen in die dritte röhre sommer in
folge zu gehen und deshalb wenn wir
nicht wollen dass das einundzwanzigste
jahrhundert ein zeitalter wird wo eine
krise die nächste überlagert müssen wir
aus dieser krise lernen dass man krisen
präventiv angeht und das gilt
insbesondere
auch für die klimakrise und als land im
herzen von europa als starkes export
land als starkes industrieland als ein
land wo die autoindustrie eine unserer
leitindustrien ist ja funktionierende
lieferketten angewiesen ist brauchen wir
der zusammenhalt innerhalb der
europäischen union
und ich kann ja noch verstehen dass am
anfang der krise als man sich unsicher
war wie umzugehen damit
nationalstaatlichen reflexen wie der
temporären exportbeschränkungen für
medizin güter die im schweren schaden in
italien in psychologischer natur
angerichtet hat reagiert hat wofür ich
allerdings wenig verständnis habe ist
dass wir jetzt nach wochen immer noch
keine vernünftigen eigenen vorschläge
präsentiert wie man europa finanziell
und wirtschaftlich zusammenhält und dann
wird immer argumentiert man müsste die
verträge ändern
frau merkel ist ein rechtlich tricky
argument nämlich sie wissen doch selber
ganz genau das ist in artikel 122 gibt
dass es schon 1975 gemeinsame anleihen
gab und deshalb hören sie auf einen
vernünftigen recovery fand mit
entsprechen einen vernünftigen
wiederaufbau frau mit entsprechenden
volumen zu blockieren nämlich das ist
das was wir dringend brauchen um die
europäische union zusammenzuhalten und
zwar in unserem ureigensten interesse
allein vw allein vw bezieht circa 20.000
unterschiedliche teile typen aus
norditalien
deshalb ist es unser ureigenstes
interesse dass die europäische union
zusammengehalten wird deshalb
verschanzen sie sich nicht hinter
fadenscheinigen rechtlichen argumenten
sondern sorgen sie dafür dass das
getragen wird
was notwendig ist und es ist ein starker
wiederaufbau vor mit den nötigen
garantien
denn in europa liegt unsere zukunft und
dafür müssen wir jetzt erhalten und
gestärkt durch die krise führen
anton hofreiter war das vorsitzender co
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen und damit der letzte aus der
reihe der fraktionsvorsitzenden in
dieser aussprache zur
regierungserklärung der bundeskanzlerin
zur coroner lage und zu den geplanten
maßnahmen um deren ausbreitung
abzumildern der nächste redner ist schon
auf dem weg zu seinem pult achim post
ist stellvertretender vorsitzender der
spd fraktion und vorsitzender der
landesgruppe nrw in seiner fraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich fange
mal am tag der heutigen
bundestagsdebatte und am tag des
heutigen eu gipfels an mit einer sache
wo glaube ich die meisten von uns
übereinstimmen
ich finde wir haben allen grund zu
selbstbewusstsein denn das was wir in
den letzten sechs wochen hingekriegt
haben in der bundesregierung und im
deutschen bundestag auch in den ländern
die hilfspakete die wir geführt haben
und verabschiedet haben
die sind nicht nur beispiellos die
können sich sehen lassen und noch
wichtiger liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
sie fangen an zu wirken und das ist doch
das wichtigste heutzutage zum zweiten
ich sage mit allen parlamentarischen
selbstbewusstsein und daran mangelt ist
mir wirklich ich finde dass das was der
bundesfinanzminister in den letzten
sechs wochen gemacht hat nämlich die
bündelung und die organisierung aller
finanziellen fähigkeiten und
möglichkeiten um daraus praktische
politik zu machen
für unternehmen und beschäftigte für
große und kleine für nationale maßnahmen
europäische maßnahmen das kann sich
sehen lassen und dafür bedanke ich mich
in aller form
herzlichen dank olaf scholz
[Applaus]
wir sind diese ostwestfalen mit ihren
zwischenrufen von der cdu liege also
jetzt kommen wir zu den dingen wo man
nachlegen müssen ob man was machen muss
wo man mehr machen muss nicht nur nach
steuern nicht nur nachbessern
das wurde da angesprochen von toni
hofreiter natürlich müssen wir jetzt
überlegen wie ein ordentliches
umfassendes nachhaltiges konjunktur und
investitionsprogramm aussehen muss das
ist doch klar dass wir das müssen und
wir müssen doch was machen wir müssen
jetzt nicht nur über deutschland reden
und über europa da komme ich gleich
drauf sondern auch über unsere kommunen
denen die einnahmen wegbrechen die
besonders leiden die schon vorher häufig
nicht auf rosen gebettet waren
für die brauchen wir jetzt einen
schutzschirm für die brauchen wir eine
altschuldenregelung und für die brauchen
wir die möglichkeit zu investieren und
deshalb lieber herr ministerpräsidenten
aus düsseldorf und münchen
hier würde ich mir einen wettlauf
wünschen einen wettbewerb wer am meisten
für die kommunen in nordrhein-westfalen
in bayern oder in ganz deutschland tut
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist die
europa zu dem gipfel von heute ich finde
der staat europas auch der start der
nationalstaaten im europäischen verbund
war schlecht holprig zum teil miserabel
er ist besser geworden deutlich besser
geworden
vor allen dingen durch eine sache das
500 milliarden programm das geschnürt
wurde das 500 milliarden programm ist
kein pappenstiel sonders die grundlage
dafür schnell unbürokratisch zu helfen
denn eins ist doch klar eins ist doch
uns allen klar unsere partner unsere
freunde in italien in spanien in
frankreich und in anderen ländern die
besonders betroffen sind die können
nicht lange warten
sie können schon gar nicht warten auf
ideologische grundsatzdebatten die
können schon gar nicht warten und wollen
auch nicht warten auch belehrungen und
auch besserwisserei und die wollen schon
überhaupt nicht warten auf neue
spardiktate die schon vor zehn jahren
nicht funktioniert haben liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
was die stattdessen brauchen ist ein
solidarisches wiederaufbauprogramm wo an
diesem tag frau bundeskanzlerin wo an
diesem tag die grundlagen dafür gelegt
werden dass wir ordentlich was auf den
weg bringen und die möglichkeiten
schaffen
zusammen mit anleihen gemeinsamen
anleihen wie das europäische parlament
sie vorgeschlagen hat zielgerichtet zu
helfen und ich glaube dass das wirklich
ist und ich weiß dass es möglich ist
ohne vertragsänderungen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zusammen
gefasst will ich mal sagen ich finde
dass wir stolz sein können doch das was
geleistet wurde ich finde dass wir noch
viel vor uns haben die kommunen waren
nur ein beispiel es gibt noch viele
andere punkte
und ich finde dass deutschland seiner
rolle in europa gerecht werden muss denn
wir sind das größte land wir sind die
stärkste volkswirtschaft und im übrigen
das was wir da tun das was wir da tun
müssen hat eine menge mit solidarität zu
tun und eine menge mit gemeinschaft aber
vor allen dingen auch mit eigeninteresse
mit unseren absatzmärkten in europa mit
lieferketten und mit waren die wir nur
in europa verkaufen können deshalb
deutschland kommt nur dann nachhaltig
wieder auf die beine wenn auch unsere
freunde und partner in europa wieder auf
die beine kommen ich will ihnen hier zum
schluss sagen die wir kolleginnen und
kollegen ich habe vertrauen in einen
handlungsfähigen staat meine fraktion
hat vertrauen in einen handlungsfähigen
staat wir haben gemeinsam vertrauen in
unsere demokratie in dieses parlament
und auch in ein funktionierendes
solidarisches europa schönen dank sagte
poß der stellvertretende vorsitzende der
spd fraktion in seinem redebeitrag haben
wir können auch noch mal auf die rein
hier im plenum des deutschen bundestags
schauen viele plätze unbesetzt
damit der nötige abstand eingehalten
werden kann das hat natürlich auch
folgen für die teilnehmer der fraktion
der mitglieder der fraktion die hier im
plenarsaal sind da muss man sich sehr
genau überlegen ob überhaupt ein
plätzchen frei ist und deswegen ist es
so geregelt dass vor allem die jeweils
zuständigen abgeordneten für bestimmte
themen im plenarsaal platz nehmen sollen
so die vorgaben der allermeisten
fraktionen und es gibt ja dann auch noch
auf der tribüne platz
für einige abgeordnete nächster redner
aktueller redner sebastian münzenmaier
auf die fraktion im harten einschnitte
in unsere grundrechte und in unser
wirtschaftsleben und andere staaten wie
südkorea oder taiwan haben früh gezeigt
wie man durch schnelles handeln und
intelligente lösungen ein vollkommenes
herunterfahren des landes vermeiden kann
das handeln dieser regierung in der
frühphase der pandemie ist stattdessen
eine einzige chronik des versagens als
die ersten nachrichten aus china zu
einem neuartigen virus eintrafen und hat
diese regierung nichts als urahn
abgeregelt wurde taten sie nichts als
unsere fraktion hier im deutschen
bundestag am 12 februar mit einem antrag
die bekämpfung der solchen ausbreitung
in deutschland mit konkreten maßnahmen
forderte lachten sie alle uns aus und
hatten stadt ist nix selbst als der iran
seit wochen als risikogebiet für das
kroner virus eingestuft war landeten am
frankfurter flughafen die maschine aus
teheran ohne probleme ohne tests ohne
quarantänemaßnahmen oder ohne
einreisesperren der gesundheitsminister
jens spahn verkündete vollmundig dass
deutschland gut vorbereitet sei lieber
ersparnis gab ihm nachfolger engpässe
bei desinfektionsmittel arztpraxen und
krankenhäuser linken unter enormen
mangel an schutzmasken die test
kapazitäten reichten bei weitem nicht
aus ihre materialbeschaffung
anstrengungen die dann hektisch und vor
allem viel zu spät starteten waren
geprägt von pleiten pech und pannen ich
erinnere mich zum beispiel um das
plötzliche verschwinden von millionen
von medizinischen atemschutzmasken
irgendwelchen flughäfen in kenia
wenn das ihre gute vorbereitung war
ersparen dann sind sie für den job nicht
geeignet wenn der deutsche bundestag in
ein arbeitszeugnis ausstellen durfte
dann wäre stets bemüht noch das beste
was da drin stehen könnte
dank ihrer anfänglichen untätigkeit und
dem dann verhängten shutdown fund ist es
corona virus mittlerweile zu einer
gefahr für unsere wirtschaft und für
unsere gesellschaft geworden
die unser land in die größte
wirtschaftskrise stürzen wird die wir je
erlebt haben
wir haben
sie haben den frühzeitigen start von
maßnahmen verschlafen und jetzt
verschlafen sie auch noch den dringend
notwendigen ausstieg aus dem shutdown
täglich melden sich verzweifelte bürger
die uns und sie vor allem anflehen die
maßnahmen endlich zu lockern damit sie
versuchen können ihre ehemals
florierenden geschäfte und unternehmen
zu retten
aber sie haben hier in ihrer
regierungserklärung ganz klargemacht wo
ihre prioritäten liegen
sie haben vielen von europa gesprochen
von europäischer solidarität im bereich
klimaschutz und davon dass die sie den
ärmsten ländern der welt die zinsen und
die tilgung von schulden erlassen wollen
wo waren ihre worte an die verzweiflung
unternehmer wo waren ihre worte an die
gastronomie frau merkel von den mehr als
220.000 gastronomischen betrieben in
deutschland mit über 2 4 millionen
beschäftigten ist jeder dritte betrieb
von insolvenz bedroht und was machen sie
bei der verkündung ihrer lockerungen sie
bieten der gastronomie und vielen
anderen branchen überhaupt keine
perspektive
stattdessen sprechen sie heute morgen
davon oder beschließen gestern nacht
dass sie die mehrwertsteuer auch speisen
endlich vereinheitlichen auf 7 prozent
reduzieren
reduzierte steuern auf speisen die man
nicht verkaufen kann also diese
bundesregierung die besteht aus
koryphäen ich muss das so ehrlich sagen
war
insgesamt sind ihre lockerung vollkommen
unzureichend und geprägt von
sinnlosigkeit man darf sich nicht im
biergarten an der frischen luft unter
wahrung der absturz und die jene regeln
treffen aber im überfüllten baumarkt mit
hunderten anderen menschen darf man sich
tummeln im großen elektronikmarkt
stecken sie sich an wenn der über 800
quadratmeter groß ist aber im kleinen
buchgeschäft auf gar keinen fall
das ist alles vollkommen willkürlich aus
der luft gegriffen und wir als auf die
fraktionen fordern deshalb ganz klar
gestatten sie jetzt allen geschäften
unabhängig von der quadratmeterzahl und
auch der gastronomie und den anderen
benachteiligten branchen endlich die
komplette öffnung unter wahrung der
abstand so die gene regel meine damen
und herren
geben sie den vielen fleißigen menschen
in diesem land endlich wieder eine
perspektive
aber das einzige was ihnen frau
bundeskanzlerin dazu einfällt sie wollen
keine ich zitiere öffnungs diskussions
orgie werde frau bundeskanzlerin
wir alle wissen dass sie ihre weisheit
und ihre getroffenen maßnahmen
wahrscheinlich für alternativlos halten
aber deshalb möchte ich sie in diesem
hohen haus daran erinnern sie sind nicht
glücklich der vierzehnte sie stehen auch
nicht über dem gesetz und auch sie sind
nur auf zeit gewählt und sie haben heute
davon gesprochen ich zitiere mit
erlaubnis des präsidenten
diese pandemie ist eine demokratische
zumutung
ich sag ihnen die demokratische zumutung
ist nicht die pandemie sondern diese
bundesregierung meine damen und herren
deswegen appelliert nochmals an sie frau
merkel an diese ganzen bundesregierung
stellen sie endlich die
verfassungsgemäße ordnung in diesem land
wieder her und geben sie den menschen
ihre freiheit zurück vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
sebastian münzenmaier war das für die
afg fraktion und der nächste redner wird
sei
der vorsitzende der csu-landesgruppe
hier im deutschen bundestag und das ist
natürlich alexander dobrindt und da
kommen wir auch noch mal einen blick
darauf werfen nach jedem redner ans pult
sorgfältigst desinfiziert und natürlich
neue gläser die gibt es ohnehin immer
aber sie sehen schon der
parlamentsdienst auch und jetzt erst
recht mit handschuhen alexander dobrindt
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen deutschland meister diese krise
viel besser als viele andere länder in
der welt das ist beileibe keine
selbstverständlichkeit sondern das hat
vor allem mit der bereitschaft der
bürgerinnen und bürger zu tun ihren
alltag umzustellen rücksicht aufeinander
zu nehmen abstand zu halten ja auch zu
verzichten um sich und andere zu
schützen und sehr geehrter herr kollege
münzen mal ich muss schon sagen dass
aufeinander rücksicht nehmen in unserem
land gesundheit und leben schützt das
ist den menschen in deutschland sehr
viel wert und deswegen sind sie bereit
auch einschnitte wahrzunehmen und dass
diese bereitschaft in der gesellschaft
deutlich größer ist als sie sie
unterstellen hilft gott sei dank dass
wir gesundbleiben meine damen und herren
dass wir diese krise aber besser
meistern können dass in vielen anderen
regionen hat auch damit zu tun dass wir
vorgesorgt haben in diesem lande dass
wir bei zentralen bereichen gut
aufgestellt sind wir haben
beispielsweise in der vergangenheit
solide gehaushaltet und dafür gesorgt
dass wir finanzielle möglichkeiten haben
und heute auch in der krise investieren
zu können schutzprogramme schutzschirm
aufspannen zu können und meine damen und
herren vielleicht erinnert man sich mal
an die eine oder andere haushaltsdebatte
der vergangenen jahre zurück da wurde
nämlich immer von der linken seite von
schulden fetisch gesprochen von der
schwarzen null vom fetisch der schwarzen
null gesprochen die man ja nicht
einhalten dürfte sondern man müsse das
geld ausgeben in der zeit der niedrigen
zinsen man kann nur sagen gut dass wir
das in der vergangenheit nicht getan
haben das geld zusammengehalten haben
nicht auf die gehört haben die immer mit
vollen händen um sich schmeißen wollten
die haushalte verschulden wollten alle
diejenigen länder in europa die jetzt
dringend auf unsere hilfe angewiesen
sind sind genau ihren modellen gefolgt
und können sich jetzt alleine nicht mehr
retten meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
und wer soll denn in europa helfen wenn
alle den gleichen weg gehen und die
verschuldung als politisches modell
anerkennen wir haben jetzt 1,4 millionen
in diesen deutschen bundestag auf den
weg gebracht vor einigen wochen den
rettungsschirmen krediten und vielem
anderen mehr
wir haben jetzt die chance in europa 500
milliarden euro über den esm über die
eba über das kurzarbeitergeld übrigens
jahr über den artikel 122 auch für
andere europäische länder zu ermöglichen
und es ist auch richtig dass wir diese
solidarität in europa zeigen um dafür zu
sorgen dass andere länder auch die
chance haben besser aus dieser krise
herauszukommen als wenn sie alleine
stünden ja das ist auch unser interesse
dass das gemeinsam möglich ist aber wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass jetzt nicht die
krise als argument genutzt wird um alle
errungenschaften der vergangenheit des
zusammenhalts über bord zu schmeißen und
wer heute leichtfertig die krise nutzt
um eine allgemeine verschuldung in
europa das wort zu reden der gefährdet
auch dieses europäische projekt und
deswegen lieber kollege und deswegen
lieber kollege toni hofreiter
wenn sie sagen dass die eu mit schulden
zusammengehalten wird dann irren sie
grundsätzlich gemeinsame schulden einen
nicht sie trennen uns in europa und
deswegen müssen wir verhindern dass es
eurobonds gibt meine damen und herren
wir haben gestern weitreichende
entscheidungen auch in dieser koalition
getroffen ich bin der bundeskanzlerin im
bundesfinanzminister dem
bundesinnenminister ausgesprochen
dankbar dass es möglich war dass wir
diese entscheidungen treffen konnten die
stärkere hilfen für den mittelstand die
stärkere hilfen für die arbeitnehmer und
die ja auch eine starthilfe für die
gastronomie beinhalten ich weiß nicht ob
das jeder hier verstanden hat wenn man
den reden zugehört hat wir schaffen die
möglichkeit für mittelständische
unternehmen dass man gewinne aus der
vergangenheit in die zukunft mit nimmt
und dafür auch verluste die jetzt
gemacht werden
im weitesten sinne miteinander
verrechnen kann
wir schaffen bei der kurzarbeit
regelungen dass die die länger in der
kürzer bleiben müssen bessergestellt
werden um ihre situation dann auch
erträglicher zu gestalten und ja wir
brauchen als gesellschaft zukünftig auch
wieder ordne orte der begegnung orte des
zusammenkommens ordne wo
gesellschaftliches leben wieder
stattfindet wie wir es auch gewohnt
waren
dazu gehören gaststätten und restaurants
und deswegen muss man dafür sorgen dass
diese gaststätten und restaurants eine
überlebenschance haben wenn sie wieder
an den start gehen und verlust die diese
in der zeit des lok downs gemacht haben
ausgleichen können und deswegen ist es
so bedeutsam und so wichtig dass wir die
mehrwertsteuer an dieser stelle absenken
damit dann in das gesellschaftliche
leben dort wieder stattfindet die chance
auf dauerhaftes überleben dieser
gastronomie möglich ist
wir haben auch ein weiterer punkt wir
haben gott sei dank starke
krankenhäusern eine starke
gesundheitsversorgung in allen regionen
in deutschland nicht kann nur sagen gut
dass wir sie haben
und wenn man manche debatten der
vergangenheit sich anschaut wo auch sehr
viel darüber diskutiert worden ist wie
viel krankenversorgung braucht man denn
in der fläche in der region
ich muss ihnen sagen für bundeskanzler
sie haben dankenswerterweise heute auch
davon gesprochen dass wir die
gesundheitsämter für die zukunft auch
stärken müssen das hat unsere volle
unterstützung es sind aber auch nicht
nur die gesundheitsämter sind auch
unsere krankenhäuser
wir brauchen eine beste medizinische
versorgung nicht nur in den
ballungsräumen in den metropolen sondern
überall in deutschland in der breiten
fläche auch auf dem land und auch das
ist eine lehre aus gerade wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass diese versorgung mit
intensivstationen mit intensivbetten um
mit normaler medizinischer spitzen
versorgung überall in deutschland
stärker möglich ist als in der
vergangenheit
[Applaus]
ich will auch darauf hinweisen dass wir
neben dieser phase in der wir uns jetzt
befinden wo wir die wirtschaftlichen
folgen der krise abfedern arbeitsplätze
sichern insolvenzen verhindern einbußen
auffangen auch darüber reden müssen was
kommt nach dieser zeit in der phase die
einen ist des aufbaus ich nenne es die
phase der innovation wir brauchen
natürlich ein innovationspaket für
europa und es wirklich auch an der
stelle noch einmal deutlich machen auch
da sega der kollege hofreiter es geht
nicht darum dass wir wörtlich es zitat
glimpflich aus dieser krise herauskommen
nicht die pflicht sondern grunderneuert
muss europa aus dieser krise
herauskommen um stärker zu sein für die
zukunft mit innovationen im bereich der
digitalisierung
der robotik der medizin der neuen
technologien das ist der auftrag um
stärker aus einer krise zu kommen und
nicht einfach nur glimpflich meine damen
und herren
[Applaus]
und dann geht es auch um die
souveränität in europa und auch darauf
will ich hinweisen über die eine oder
andere abhängigkeit deutschlands und
europas in der welt konnte man sich in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten in
der tat nur wundern ja wir sind ein
weltoffenes land und wir wollen den
freien handel aber austausch mit anderen
darf nicht zur einseitigen abhängigkeit
führen und deswegen müssen wir über
diese frage eigene handlungsfähigkeit in
europa wieder stärker reden eine
europäische souveränitäts offensive
staaten ja versorgung mit wichtigen
medizinprodukten mit medikamenten
notwendig dass in europa alleine
sicherzustellen komponenten für
kritische schutzbekleidung ja das muss
in europa sichergestellt werden andere
elemente auch dringend notwendig und
dafür zusagen lieber wirtschaftsminister
dass wir in einer phase in der wir aus
einer krise uns wieder raus bewegen mit
unseren unternehmen dafür sorgen dass
wir produkte in europa und deutschland
herstellen können eigene versorgung
sichern
und übrigens dafür sorgen dass diese
unternehmen wenn sie in schwierigkeiten
geraten jetzt nicht auf dem rand
rammschlag der welt verstreut werden
sondern dass wir dafür sorgen dass auch
die unternehmen in deutschland und
europa eine chance weiter haben das ist
aufgabe der politik ist dafür zu sorgen
dass wegen dank alexander dobrindt
vorsitzender der csu-landesgruppe setzt
darauf dass es nach der krise ein
runderneuertes europa auch gibt ja
einige bisher übliche gewohnheiten oder
gewohnheiten und umständen werden
sicherlich auf den prüfstand gestellt
werden müssen in den nächsten wochen
oder sogar monaten wie nächste rednerin
in dieser debatte ist bärbel bas
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
spd-fraktion und da zuständig unter
anderem für den bereich gesundheit meine
damen und herren
deutschland liegt auf dem zweiten platz
beim kampf gegen das corona virus so
jedenfalls das ergebnis einer
internationalen vergleichsstudie die am
wochenende bekannt wurde und auch in
internationalen medien wird immer wieder
anerkennend über unsere maßnahmen
berichtet und dafür gibt es einige
gründe
dazu zählen vor allem frühzeitige und
weitverbreitete tests und eine hohe
anzahl an intensivbetten als bei uns die
ersten fälle aufgetreten sind konnten
wir die kontaktperson schnellen testen
und sie auch isolieren
aber auch wir kamen irgendwann an einen
punkt an dem die infektionsketten nicht
mehr nachvollziehbar waren und das virus
begangen sich schnell auszubreiten und
diese schnell ausbreiten mussten wir
stoppen
unser ziel ist es das gesundheitssystem
funktionsfähig zu halten
wir wollen dass alle die an carola
erkranken so gut wie möglich auch
versorgt werden können und wir wollen
natürlich auch dass die die einen
herzinfarkt erleiden einen schlaganfall
einen unfall haben auch noch einen platz
in den krankenhäusern bekommen und auf
den intensivstationen unser
gesundheitssystem funktioniert hier
bisher gut und die maßnahmen die wir
ergreifen und die zahl der
neuinfektionen sinkt dann ist das ein
erfolg den wir den maßnahmen die wir
jetzt ergriffen haben auch zu verdanken
haben
dieser erfolg und das spüren wir alle
ist mit großen belastung verbunden
uns fehlt der kontakt zu freunden und
familie und familien müssen arbeit und
kinderbetreuung in dafür oft viel zu
kleinen wohnungen unter einen hut
bringen
unternehmen stellen
die arbeit ein und viele menschen
verlieren ihre arbeit oder fragen sich
ob sie in ein paar wochen überhaupt noch
einen job haben wir alle wünschen uns
dass kann ich glaube auch für alle im
haus sagen dass dieser locker und so
schnell wie möglich beendet wird
es ist auch richtig dass wir darüber
diskutieren wie wir wieder zu einem
halbwegs normalen leben zurückkehren wir
müssen aber genauso ehrlich auch die
frage beantworten und diskutieren ab
wann das denn möglich ist und herr
lindner wir wissen mehr haben sie gesagt
das stimmt aber will es noch lange nicht
alles wir brauchen eine viel breitere
datenbasis auf der wir eben genau solche
lockerungs entscheidungen treffen können
und wir müssen viel mehr testen als
bisher
wir müssen wissen wo infektionsherde und
wie sie entstehen und wir müssen
einzelne infektionen auf wieder
nachverfolgen können
das sind die entscheidenden dinge die
wir brauchen neben einer viel breiteren
begleitforschung um auch mehr über das
virus zu lernen und warum das wichtig
ist will ich noch mal sagen weil wir das
vorhin auch schon angesprochen haben
es geht um öffnung von schulen und kitas
es gibt erste studien die darauf
hinweisen dass kleine kinder cupid 19
vielleicht nicht übertragen
das sind aber erst nur einzelne hinweise
dass ist noch nicht gesichert
und jetzt kann man natürlich anfangen
jetzt schon schulen und kitas wieder zu
öffnen
aber dann müssen wir uns die alternative
angucken das der aufforstung kann man ja
sein dass man dann die risikogruppen und
die älteren menschen auf der anderen
seite isoliert und jetzt guck ich mal
einrichtung weil das für mich keine
alternative ist sie wollen doch nicht
ihren vorsitzenden als beispiel den
herrn gauland isolieren
das ist für mich keine alternative
deswegen sage ich das ganz deutlich
aber wenn wir über breite öffnung reden
dann müssen wir auch darüber reden wie
wir risikogruppen und ältere menschen
schützen wollen deshalb wollte ich das
an diesem beispiel sagen wir dürfen das
nicht zu schnell machen davor kann ich
nur warnen es fehlen einfach belege auch
welche über diese isolierung und welche
risikogruppen wie am ende haben
und eins will ich auch noch erwähnen die
schutzschirme die wir haben die wir
gespannt haben die haben noch lücken und
das kann ich auch dem herrn brinkhaus
nicht ganz ersparen ja das kostet alles
geld aber wir haben zum beispiel nach
wie vor noch keine hilfe für studierende
die ihre nebenjobs verloren haben
für angehörige die die in die pflege
jetzt einsteigen müssen und
verdienstausfall haben wir haben
gemeinnützige unternehmen die nicht
unter den schutzschirm fallen das müssen
wir noch regeln da können wir nicht
sagen haben wir jetzt kein geld mehr für
und übrigens die boni die wirkungsvoll
gesprochen haben für pflegekräfte
das darf jetzt auch nicht am
finanzstreit irgendwie scheitern das ist
versprochen worden
und das muss für die pflegekräfte
aufkommen und deshalb sollten wir uns
hier auch nochmal stark machen und die
weiteren anstrengung und diskussionen
auch nutzen um genau diese dinge noch zu
unterstützen denn für uns
sozialdemokraten und sozialdemokrat ist
wichtig dass wir nicht nur auf die
lauten hören sondern dass wir eben auch
genau an die soziale struktur denken und
an die vielen menschen die jetzt in
dieser krise viel unterstützen und noch
keinen schutz schimpft gefunden haben
unter die wir sie stellen
dafür wollen wir weiter kämpfen als
sozialdemokraten und wir würden uns sehr
freuen wenn sie das unterstützen
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist ihr kollege eckhard
rehberg cdu csu präsident liebe
kolleginnen kollegen lag der
schuldenstand des bundes ist rund 1,2
millionen euro
er ist in den letzten sieben jahren
nicht gewachsen und wir haben auf den
weg gebracht
einen garantierahmen von über einer
billion und wie 156 milliarden neue
schulden aufgenommen wo von 100
milliarden getilgt werden müssen
so sieht es der artikel 115 grundgesetz
vor und ist richtig gut angelegtes geld
in den bereichen gesundheitsschutz bei
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern und
für unternehmer und selbständige
was mich etwas irritiert hat heute an
diese debatte außer von seiten der union
hat niemand darauf hingewiesen dass wir
auch die finanzpolitische solidität in
der zukunft im blick behalten sollten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich fand
es sehr ehrlich das gestern ihren spahn
im haushaltsausschuss darauf hingewiesen
hat dass die rücklagen des
gesundheitsfonds aufgebraucht sind
ich würde mir das bei anderen
ministerien und ministern auch wünschen
stellt sich doch die frage wie lange
reicht die rücklage bei der
arbeitslosenversicherung wie lange
reichen die 26 milliarden wie lange
reichen die 40 milliarden bei der rente
wie lange deckt decken die einnahmen bei
der pflege die ausgaben gehen wir dann
wirklich davon aus dass wir die nächsten
wochen monaten und jahren genau die
einnahmesituation haben werden die im
jahr 2009 10 wie vor caron oder sie auch
ein bisschen innehalten ein bisschen
solidität auch durchaus angebracht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe mittlerweile fünf enkel und ich
hab ja mal an dieser stelle gesagt ich
bin stolz drauf keine neuen schulden zu
machen
ich sage auch an dieser stelle ich
möchte meinen kindern und enkeln nicht
1,5 millionen oder 2 billionen euro
schulden als bund überlassen und auch
mit blick auf europa europa lebt doch
von der deutschen finanzpolitische
solidität dass wir diese garantien geben
können und dass sich andere staaten so
günstig refinanzieren können liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen deswegen noch
ein wort zur europa kollege hofreiter
der kollege der artikel 125 ist
einschlägig der artikel 122 absatz 2 und
was noch einschlägige ist für mich für
mich als abgeordneter im deutschen
bundestag ist das grundgesetz und sind
die urteile des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ich sage ihnen
sehr klar und deutlich ich als gewählter
deutscher abgeordneter möchte ein
uneingeschränktes budgetrecht über den
bundeshaushalt haben und auch weiter
behalten so uneingeschränkt und da haben
wir den rückendeckung mehrerer
bundesverfassungsgerichts vorurteile und
ich rate ihnen dringend mal die
ausarbeitung des wissenschaftlichen
dienstes der bundestagsverwaltung zu
diesem thema sich durch zulegen werden
sie durch zulegen das macht nicht ihre
auffassung sein
ich sage nur
wir wollen aus unionsfraktion unser
budget recht behalten und sehen uns hier
auf dem boden des grundgesetzes und ich
möchte auch regelwerk gestatten sie eine
zwischenfrage und kittner kollege
rehberg in der kasse zwischenfragen
zugelassen haben wir haben über die
frage von sogenannten corona bonds auch
schon im haushaltsausschuss geredet sie
haben dort die rechtliche einschätzung
auch da gegeben diese aktien der rede
dagegen haben es ihnen aber bekannt dass
die frage ob er eine
gesamtschuldnerische haftung macht einen
unterschied macht bei der frage von
gemeinsamen europäischen anleihen sind
auch bekannt dass die europäische union
heute schon gemeinsame anleihen
herausgibt das hat man die bundesliga
auch beantwortet und zwar ist die tiere
die ausgabe von anleihen für die fsm das
palace of payment programm und die makro
financial assistance ist verständlich
eng begrenzt übersieht auf rechtsakte
der sprecher fraglicher grundlage
danach hatte ich die bundesregierung
gefragt das sind gemeinsame europäische
anleihen und wir können auch für einen
großen recovery front wir schlagen eine
billion euro vor wie andere europäische
länder auch dann gemeinsame europäische
anleihen begeben die sind dann teil
schuldnerin also begrenzt für den
deutschen bundes heisst als ihnen
rechtlich klar definiert hat den vorgang
als recovery fand wo man vor gericht zu
welchen maßnahmen man das ausgeben kann
zum beispiel auch für ausgaben die im
zusammengang green deal stehen das heißt
auch dass erfüllt die vorgaben des
verfassungsgerichts erfüllt auch die
vorgaben europäischer verträge wenn man
auf der region zahlen 20 das machen
würde hätte gemeinsam gemacht hat ihn
die mitgliedsländer dann auch gemeinsam
garantieren aber keine gemeinschaftliche
haftung für viva corona bond das ist
richtig trotzdem kann man es regeln dass
man in höhe von sehr großen volumina
deutlich mit gemeinsamer anleihen den
wiederaufbau von juve reform finanziert
und ist die bundesliga bereit
unionsfraktion bereits so einen weg zu
gehen wie in anderen länder
vorgeschlagen haben
um auch diesen wiederaufbau europa und
die bewältigung dieser großen
ökonomischen krise in europa jetzt auch
gemeinsam bedarf zu finanzieren
herr kollege kindler kollege kindler wir
haben gezeigt und die bundesregierung
hat gezeigt und ich glaube sie wird es
auch heute zeigen die bundeskanzlerin
dass wir solidarisch sind wir haben ein
paket auf den weg gebracht mit drei
säulen 200 milliarden bei der alp 100
milliarden schuhe kurzarbeitergeld und
240 milliarden über ssl den esm
und hier glaube ich ist es eher an
gezeigt dass wir als deutscher bundestag
darauf drängen dass europa die
europäische kommission das umsetzt
denn schnelle hilfe ist aktuell die
beste hilfe in der krise oder für uns
dann möglicherweise auf die debatte
begeben die sie eben angerissen haben
habe ich über der sprechen auch drei
ausdrücklich wenn wir uns über einen
wiederaufbau und erhalten das hat die
bundeskanzlerin deutlich gemacht dann
soll das im rahmen des eu haushaltes
sein
man muss nicht neben dem eu haushalt
immer nur das thema korrosionsschutz
warum muss ich ein wiederaufbau von noch
mal wieder neu erfinden wenn ich
strukturfonds hat warum ich warum nutze
ich nicht vorhandene instrumente ich
komme aus einem neuen bundesland ohne
die europäischen strukturfonds sie in
mecklenburg vorpommern heute nicht so
aus wie es aussieht und warum soll das
nicht in italien spanien frankreich oder
griechenland auch möglich sein kollege
kindler und insoweit wir brauchen aus
meiner sicht nicht monatelange
jahrelange debatten wir neue instrumente
sondern schnelles handeln ist richtiges
handeln auch und für europa herzlichen
dank liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
triberg der haushaltspolitische sprecher
der fraktion cdu csu bis gestern oder
mindestens vorgestern noch ein großer
kritiker irgendwie was die erhöhung des
kurzarbeitergeldes angeht was ja der
koalitionsausschuss in der nacht
beschlossen hat nicht so rednerin auf
meiner liste katja lagarde für die
fraktion cdu csu auch eine der
stellvertreterinnen sicherheit und auch
einen trend zur re ideologisierung und
auch wenn in europa und auch hier im
hohen haus die europäische solidarität
von einigen angezweifelt wird für uns in
der cdu csu fraktion gehört europäische
solidarität unserer grundüberzeugung
unserer politischen dna denn die
europäische union ist eben keine
schönwetterveranstaltung sondern sie
beweist sich im täglichen wir deutschen
sind solidarisch mit unseren
europäischen partnern und wir sind es
übrigens immer gewesen auch in den
schweren stunden der staatsschuldenkrise
und das liebe kollegen liebe kolleginnen
kollegen dürfen wir uns wieder von
einigen hier im hohen hause noch von
populisten in rom paris oder madrid
kaputtreden lassen
wir helfen im gesundheitlichen bereich
so haben wir wiederholt
intensivpatienten aus italien frankreich
und niederlande aufgenommen wir haben
medizinische hilfsgüter nach
entschuldigung nach italien geschickt
und über 100 beatmungsgeräte nach
großbritannien und spanien geliefert
solidarisch sind wir auch lieber herr
hofreiter bei der bekämpfung der
wirtschaftlichen folgen auf europäischer
ebene haben wir in kürzester zeit
wichtige grundlagen für finanzhilfen in
höhe von 540 milliarden euro geschaffen
und für uns ist klar unsere solidarität
wird hier nicht enden lieber her
hofreiter auch hier noch einmal für sie
das klare bekenntnis auch zu weiteren
maßnahmen des wiederaufbaus der
wirtschaft werden wir unterstützen
und wer sich jetzt hinstellten
angesichts der dramatischen lage corona
bonds als alleinige lösung fordert der
gefährdet in der tat den zusammenhalt in
europa die vorredner haben es deutlich
gemacht wir sind keine schlechten
europäer nur weil wir als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion corona bonds nicht
als lösung für europa sehen im gegenteil
ist es vielmehr so wie im echten leben
falsche solidarität die am ende alle
schlecht ist eben falsch verstandene
solidarität und es gilt eben auch das
was er hier eben gesagt hat für uns geht
es und reift brinkhaus davor für uns
geht es auch um fiskalische solidarität
auch in der krise sehr geehrte damen und
herren ja wir streiten in europa und das
ist auch richtig so dass wir das tun
über den richtigen weg es sind viele
staaten die hier miteinander
zusammenarbeiten noch mal was wir nicht
brauchen können sind ideologisch oder
rückwärtsgewandte debatten was wir jetzt
brauchen sind pragmatische und
zielgerichtete maßnahmen für ein europa
das gestärkt aus der krise heraus geht
genau das wollen wir denn nur ein
starkes europa wird am ende des tages im
globalen wettbewerb im akteuren wie
china oder den usa bestand haben und
dabei sehr verehrte damen und herren
sind drei punkte für mich ganz zentral
erstens müssen wir an der nachhaltigen
ausgestaltung der wirtschaft festhalten
und hier sehe ich die krise auch
wirklich als eine chance schnell auf
zukunftsorientierte technologie
umzurüsten der green deal der
europäischen kommission ist hierfür eine
wichtige grundlage denn war es auch wir
befinden uns ja längst mitten in der
nächsten krise der klimakrise es ist so
es ist nicht nur mal wieder ein warmer
märz sondern das hat mittlerweile
natürlich eine dimension die auch für
uns gravierende folgen haben wird
und gerade deshalb wird es für uns
überlebenswichtig sein den weg zu einer
klimaneutralen eu weiter zu gehen
zweiter ist und auch das hat die
kanzlerin vorhin angesprochen ist es
ganz wichtig wenn wir die europäische
union als globalen akteur sie in europa
muss autonome und unabhängiger von trick
märkten werden
wir müssen strategisch wichtige
industriebereiche wie den verteidigungs
oder transportsektor stärken und auch
hier hat die kommission gute ansätze und
ihrer industrie strategie vorgelegt die
wir weiter entwickeln müssen
und drittens müssen wir dringend in die
digitalisierung von wirtschaft und
bildung investieren wir brauchen den
digitalen binnenmarkt auf europäische
plattform
wir machen videokonferenzen über summen
und webex das könnten wir vielleicht
auch europäisieren
und das ist wichtig wenn es die
europäische union ernst damit meinen
standards zu setzen
und gerade hier können wir auf dem von
anderen mitgliedsstaaten wehren wenn ich
daheim an meinen homeschooling denke
oder auch home office deutschland geht
es gut nur gut in einer innovativen
starken europäischen union lassen sie
uns das gemeinsam anpacken in einer
starken gemeinschaft von solidarischen
staaten herzlichen dank einer der
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
der cdu csu fraktion hier im deutschen
bundestag war dass ich ja leicht und man
konnte es der rede ein klein wenig
entnehmen hat sie da unter anderem dem
schwerpunkt europa politik und jetzt
haben wir eine die wir hier lange nicht
gesehen und natürlich auch nicht gehört
haben frauke petry fraktionslos
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren
niemand bestreitet dass uns das
neuartige virus kubik 19 kalt erwischt
hatte ich die frage lautet nur warum
meine damen und herren wer ist
verantwortlich dafür dass die
sprichwörtliche blaupause der
pandemieplan von 2012 offenbar nicht
umgesetzt wurde
es wird aufgabe dieses parlament eines
späteres seien zu klären wie es
passieren konnte dass wir am ende nahezu
ohne schutzmaske und andere schutz aus
richtige klappt mussten obwohl der
letzte bundestag eine sehr detaillierte
ausarbeitung dazu gefertigt hat dass sie
frau merkel sich scheinbar demütig
einreihen und bürgern vermitteln dass
wir alle gemeinsam in eine milchige kur
oder glas vogel blicken ist taktisch
klug aber leider unehrlich die pandemie
ist keine neuartige erfahrung epidemien
pandemien sind wiederkehrende ereignisse
und der bundestag 2012 wusste dass
offensichtlich und sie waren damals
bundeskanzlerin
wir sind nicht am anfang einer pandemie
wir sind seit mitte seit anfang des
jahres 2020 global mittendrin nur hat
die bundesregierung oder auch der
gesundheitsminister sparen vorgezogen
die dramatischen signale aus china und
später italien zu ignorieren
die masken was gerade frau merkel so
möchte ich es bezeichnen keine maske
schädliche maske vielleicht maske und
bei doch maske am besten in heimarbeit
genäht und nicht professionell
medizinischen nutzen diese masken was
gerade wird zu fürchte ich in einem
atemzug später mit pauls unwahrheiten
über die massenvernichtungswaffen im
irak zu nennen seien und sie ist so
leicht zu entlaufen
warum stehen wir doch in deutschland
vergleichsweise gut da bei kommunen und
landkreise bürgermeister und freiwillige
bürger vor ort funktioniert haben in
sozialstation und kann
neu seien ganz ohne basta aus dem
kanzleramt der föderalismus hat viel
besser funktioniert als mancher erwartet
hat und er hätte noch viel besser
funktionieren können wenn es frühzeitig
grenzkontrollen und einreise beschränken
und für risikogruppen gegeben hätte auch
markus söder und armin laschet gehört
dank sie sind vorgeprescht sie haben
druck auf die bundesregierung ausgeübt
erste notwendige beschränkungen und
jetzt auch für notwendige lockerungen
und sich verdienen ist nicht bekannt zu
werden
sie frau merkel wirken getrieben wie
unter anderen voraussetzungen vor fünf
jahren kraftvolles agieren geht anders
ich habe nun trotzdem einige fragen an
sie und die bundesregierung wie werden
sie zukünftig zwischen den pandemie
schäden und den wirtschaftlichen folgen
ab die noch dramatischer ausfallen
könnten was haben wir denn erreicht wir
halt maximal im geschützt den totalen
kollaps verhindert aber wie teuer und
dieser kollaps oder der nicht verfolgte
kollaps zu stehen kommt das können sie
nicht sagen hier fehlt er planen und ich
bitte sie hören sie auf maßnahmen
angebliche maßnahmen wie die aussetzung
der insolvenzantragspflicht zu
initiieren oder zu verkünden ist gebe
keine arbeitslosen durch corona sie
wissen viel besser dass es unmöglich ist
was tun sie um den steuerzahlern
zukünftige lasten zu ersparen bitte ich
brauche ein eindeutiges nein zu
euro-bonds verdienen und was wir
brauchen ist mehr forschung in viele
medizinische ansätze ich erwähne dabei
das inzwischen bekannt ist dass coop 19
offenbar ein helfer bakterium aus der
sogenannten prewo teller familie hat
werden wir hier erfolgreich lässt sich
erhärten dass wir einen therapieansatz
haben dann wäre es möglich schul und
kitas schon bald wieder zu öffnen und
somit überlassen sie den
wissenschaftlern praktikern vor ort das
kraftvoll agieren und fördern sie die
demokratische kontroverse das wissen sie
als physikerin besser als manch anderer
frauke petry war das früher mal
unterlagen sie ja auch ins neue des
versuchs gleichen partei unternommen
kollegen lauener zwischen abgewickelt
carsten linnemann ist der nächste redner
aus dem rhein
der cdu csu fraktion und auch er ist
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
die weltwirtschaft ist mit dem corona
virus infiziert länder auf diesem globus
die 50 prozent des weltweiten
bruttosozialproduktes ausmachen befinden
sich derzeit im lockdown das trifft
unsere wirtschaft mit voller wucht es
geht auch ins mark gerade für den
mittelstand der sehr stark
exportorientiert ist die unter den
abgebrochenen oder gebrochenen
lieferketten bleiben es trifft aber auch
unsere nationale wirtschaft wir haben
branchen die derzeit keine umsätze
machen aber laufende kosten
ich denke da an die veranstalter an den
einzelhandel an die gastronomie an die
reise an das reisegewerbe schausteller
messebauer hotels und vieles mehr
der arbeitsmarkt das muss man nicht dann
sagen der ist heute 30 mal heftiger
getroffen als 2008/2009 bei der letzten
rezession wir haben heute über 700.000
firmen unternehmen wie die das
instrument kurzarbeit nutzen
das ist fast ein drittel aller
unternehmen in deutschland
das geht ins mark darauf hat die
regierung reagiert unterm strich bei
aller kritik richtig und die cdu csu
fraktion das hat auch ralf rinke aus
eben deutlich gemacht unterstützt das
vorgehen nur klar ist auch dass wurde
deutlich auch unsere möglichkeiten sind
nicht unendlich sondern endlich wie
können nicht monatelang das wissen wir
alle so weitermachen als gäbe es kein
morgen auch unser start kommt irgendwann
an seine grenzen und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir uns heute gedanken
machen
auch über die zeit nach corona welche
trends gibt es
wie wird die entwicklung sein ich sehe
vor allen dingen drei trends erstens die
welt wird digitaler sein unternehmen und
staaten erleben gerade einen crashkurs
das hat die kollegin katja like hat
gesagt im e-commerce in digitalem
arbeiten und digitaler
aktion zweitens die globalen
lieferketten werden sich neu ordnen
die lagerhaltung wird zunehmen das macht
was aus für das unternehmen das
unternehmen den widerstandsfähiger sein
aber auf der anderen seite auch weniger
profitabel
und jetzt kommt ein dritter punkt der es
für mich zentrales wird ein
konzentrationsprozess in der wirtschaft
geben
flankiert mit dem umstand dass der staat
sich mehr einmischt mehr beteiligt mehr
umverteilt
dieses beides zusammen ein
konzentrationsprozess in der wirtschaft
und ein ausgeweiteter staat mag im
einzelfall notwendig ja sogar richtig
sein das sehen wir im moment aber
langfristig ist das natürlich gift für
wachstum für wohlstand und beschäftigung
deswegen glaube ich brauchen wir das
auch meine überzeugung ein kluges
vorgehen jetzt in dieser krise wir
müssen ab und helfen
da geht es vor allen dingen um
liquidität das was heute nacht
geschlossen wurde
stichwort verlustverrechnung im
steuerlichen bereich absolut richtig
absolut richtige maßnahme hier müssen
wir weiterkommen
auch sozialversicherungsbeiträge länger
stunden mai ist zu früh
auch das thema fälligkeit abschaffen der
vor fälligkeit der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge denke ich
jetzt ein zielgerichtetes instrument um
der wirtschaft zu helfen
wir müssen auch europäisch helfen und
zwar mit voller buch der kollege rehberg
hat das angesprochen wie ich finde
richtig mit viel geld helfen aber auch
das wurde deutlich wie dürfen
solidarität nicht mit
haftungsgemeinschaft um verwechseln
wir müssen zweitens eine perspektive
geben den firmen dass sie genau wissen
unter welchen auflagen und bedingungen
sie wieder langsam fahrt aufnehmen
können und drittens müssen wir den exit
vorbereiten
wir müssen immer wissen dass die
instrumente wie jetzt auf den weg
bringen denke da beispielsweise an den
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds mit
staatsbeteiligung dass das immer
befristet ist dass wir da wieder raus
müssen die soziale marktwirtschaft kann
das auf dauer nicht aushalten und wir
müssen allen entgegentreten die eine
verstaatlichung von unternehmen und eine
vergemeinschaftung von haftung
vorantreiben wollen für soziale
marktwirtschaft und das ganz klar zu
sagen ist und bleibt unser
erfolgskonzept vor der krise in der
krise und nach der krise
vielen dank klassen lindemann einer der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der cdu csu
fraktion und auch einer der verfechter
inneren der union für eine schnellere
öffnung des wirtschaftlichen lebens es
ist ja auch in diesem beitrag
hier nochmal angezogen wir sind beim
letzten redner in dieser aussprache zur
regierungserklärung der bundeskanzler
die csu wenn man so will hat noch einmal
das wort mit georg nüßlein präsident
meine damen meine herren
momentan wird eine frage ziemlich häufig
diskutiert nämlich die frage warum kommt
dieses land rief jetzt schon ziemlich
glimpflich durch diese krise was
unterscheidet das gesundheitssystem in
deutschland von anderen
ich will dass ganz kurz
schlagwortartig beleuchten erstens wir
haben gut ausgebildetes leistungsbereit
des leistungsfähiges personal nicht nur
akademisch ausgebildete personal ich
sagte es bewusst aus politischen gründen
zweitens wir haben keine
zugangsschranken die versicherung macht
hier einiges aus das mag und den usa ein
problem sein
drittens wir haben eine flächendeckende
versorgung unsere krankenhäuser auch im
ländlichen raum der seite alexander
dobrindt vor allem beleuchtet die ist
ganz wichtig und wir müssen sie in
zukunft noch stärker schützen und ins
blickfeld der politik rücken
viertens wir haben keine staatsmedizin
denn wenn sie nach england gucken können
sich anschauen was da geleistet wird und
das ist etwas was mich nicht
hoffnungsvoll macht dass ihr konzept
irgendeine chance hat etwas zu
verbessern ganz im gegenteil und
fünftens wir haben mal eine politik die
früh und klar eingegriffen hat an der
stelle und gemeinsam mit duldsamen
bürgern die das verstanden haben um was
es geht tatsächlich dafür gesorgt haben
dass wir das problem jetzt komme ich
jetzt sehr häufig sind sie gleich die
anderen ran
jetzt komme ich zu dem was mich heute an
der debatte am meisten schockiert hat
das war die rede von herrn münzenmaier
ja hier sitzt dann genau daran hat sich
zurückgehalten des mad men
altersweisheit zu tun haben das könnte
auch damit zu tun haben dass er gewusst
habe dass der nächste redner was anderes
hier vortragen wird
aber das ist nur ein vorgeschmack auf
das was uns jetzt den weg bringen wenn
das was wir politisch eher wanders haben
wenn das wasser unser gesundheitssystem
leistet am schluss erfolg habt dann
werden sie von denen man die ganze zeit
jetzt nicht gehört habe aus ihren
löchern kommen und werden sorgen das war
alles unnötige habt ohne noten
wirtschaft ruiniert das und jenes
gemacht das würdet ihr tun nachdem er
vorher
nachdem man vorher euch versteckt habt
ja sie waren sich das anschauen und
werden dann wenn alles gut gegangen ist
den neunmalklugen spielen damit die
fahrbarkeit des ganzen ausnutzen und
werden sagen wir von der afg wir haben
es gewusst bei dem alles ganz anders
machen können und ich sage es an der
stelle so prophezeien an der stelle weil
ich weiß dass es so kommt und weil man
sie jetzt schon sagen muss weil sie es
genauso letztendlich machen müssen
natürlich gibt es ein paar dinge die man
noch verbessern kann das ist die
versorgung mit der schutzkleidung da
sind wir jetzt auf dem weg zu sagen
lasst uns die in deutschland zu
produzieren ganz entscheiden ja es geht
auch um die frage wo sind die grenzen
der globalisierung können wir bei
medikamenten in zukunft können wir bei
mir die ganze zeit so muss ich auch noch
laute wann wir können wir bei der
versorgung mit medikamenten dafür sorge
tragen dass er das nicht in china in
asien kaufen müssen sondern dass es bei
uns gilt dem auf maßnahmen
ich bin zum beispiel jemand der dafür
eintreten wird dass wir in zukunft nicht
nur dann wenn man rabattverträge machen
also medikamente ausschalten dass wir
dann nicht einem den zuschlag geben
sondern mindestens zwei und das da von
einer zuschlag bekommt wenn eine
europäische lieferkette nachbar ist also
die dinge werden wir ändern müssen werde
vollständig richtig aber das jetzt schon
anfangen das was wir hier tun und was
die breite mehrheit der menschen zu
recht mit sagt zu diffamieren ist
schändlich sämtliche wir werden
natürlich wir reden natürlich öffnungen
kommen müssen und da kommt klagt hat auf
die alten verantwortung an ganz klar
aber die eigenverantwortung der menschen
ist nicht die lösung sondern die
bedingung dafür dass die lockerungen die
jetzt auf dem weg sind die linien
und ich appelliere daran dass die
menschen es dann auch in so entsprechen
mit umsetzen dann wird es uns glücken
relativ zügig auch wieder in ein
sinnvolles wirtschaft und
gesellschaftsleben einzusteigen vieler
zinsen und soweit also die aussprache
zur regierungserklärung der
bundeskanzlerin georg nüßlein csu auch
da stellvertretender vorsitzender eine
fraktion cdu csu war der letzte redner
hat am anfang gesagt warum kommt
deutschland so glimpflich durch die
krise der warnen virologen ja inzwischen
dass man da im moment noch nicht so
wirklich sicher sein könne und wenn man
sich die sogenannte re produktionszahl
anguckt also wie viel rein statistisch
betrachtet menschen die infiziert sind
andere anstecken da liegt die zahl
offenbar wieder bei 0,9 vor ostern lag
sie noch bei 0,7 also es ist tatsächlich
weiterhin vorsicht geboten abstand
geboten sowieso ohne ja- und die
entwarnung oder für eine entwarnung
scheint es jedenfalls wenn man mit
führenden virologen folgt auch wenn sie
im detail unterschiedliche
einschätzungen haben ist dann offenbar
doch noch zu warnen